Oh my goodness.
Ladies and gentlemen,
here we go again.
Here we go again.
This episode of the Joe Rogan
experience.
I just did some UFC stuff today,
so I almost said the ultimate insider,
the Arctic Joe Rogan.
And trying to switch gears.
I switched gears from Sports Guy
Persona.
Uh,
we uh,
were sponsored by Ting.
Ting is a,
a mobile company.
If you go to Rogan.ting.com,
you can see all the information and you
could also save 25 bucks off of any of
their phones or,
or the service I believe,
I believe it's applicable to a either or
with ting is,
is a very ethical cell phone company.
And what they're trying to do is they're
trying to offer you the same service
that a big network like sprint would
offer you,
but they're trying to make it so that
you can cancel anytime you want and
there's no hidden fees and they,
uh,
they,
they have it set up so that if you
don't,
uh,
if you don't use a certain amount of
minutes,
say if like a you're on one plan and you
use something that would qualify you for
a lesser plan on your next bill that's
reflected,
they reimburse you for it.
They,
they,
they make it so that you're paying for
what you use.
And really that is how it should be.
I mean,
it's a,
that's how every company should be the
idea of getting locked into contracts.
It's fucking gross.
You don't have to get locked in the
contracts and you don't have to suffer
with shit phones either.
They have the top of the line,
android phones,
including the Samsung Galaxy s three,
which I have,
which is just a stunning phone.
And the Samsung Galaxy note,
Opi hasn't.
You have the s,
the s three,
I sure do.
It's a
combat asphalt whistle.
Earlier I was talking to him about that
whistle that always got me embarrassed
when
the services a gray.
A lot of people,
um,
uh,
love the sprint service in La.
I know Joey raves about,
he says it's great.
Um,
and the,
uh,
like I said,
the phones that the quality of the
phones is top notch.
I mean they have the best phones in the
world now if you want to like,
have like a one purpose device.
These,
especially the galaxy note to the new
one.
I saw one today.
I,
you know,
it's a little vague.
I've resisted getting one,
but I think I can't resist any longer.
I think I have to have one of those
fucking things,
isn't it?
I am a Dork.
Okay.
The big heads and big hands.
I have a big head and normal.
I'm not going to.
Yeah,
a
little fit May.
Maybe.
Maybe that's what I need.
Yeah.
Anyway,
go do a Rogan.ting.com
and you can save 25 bucks and it has all
the other information.
This is a company though.
We've,
uh,
we've been working with them for a long
time,
very,
very cool people and what they're trying
to do is just be involved in an ethical
business and we support that.
So Rogan.ting.com.
We're also sponsored by on it.
Of course o n n it if you have never
heard of it or anything,
you must be new to the podcast because a
fucking said everything I could say
about on it.
Wait,
we got,
we got the Himalayan sea salt and the
salt.
Yeah,
we just continue to,
to have cool shit that we,
uh,
we're,
we're selling people.
That's all.
We're trying to do it on it.
Hey,
should they get pepper?
Maybe?
Yeah.
Why would you wouldn't.
Have you ever heard of a place that
sells salt and pepper?
Well,
not normally,
but see Himalayan sea salt known as a,
a more of like a health supplement.
Like people put it in their water when
they get up in the morning,
find some pepper to go with it.
It's only good if you're cooking William
Pepper.
Pepper is only good if you're cooking.
I need to find out the benefits of
Himalayan Sea salt,
but I think it was just like I said with
the killer bee.
Honey,
we have killer bee honey.
Why do we have killer bee honey?
Because it sounds gangster as fuck,
right?
It's,
it's bad ass to Jackson killer bees and
take their fucking honey and that's also
bad ass to get some salt that came from
the Himalayas.
I don't know why.
I don't know why it doesn't make any
sense.
A lot of his fucking stupid but.
But it is a fact that Himalayan sea salt
sounds dope and if you have it over your
house,
chicks will think you're smarter than
you really are.
You know,
if a girl comes over at some guy's house
and he's got some Himalayan sea salt
laying around,
she might go,
well maybe he knows things.
You know,
just maybe it's just not good at
communicating.
What is your fucking pepper who also
have a force,
a hemp protein powder.
It's the finest quality hemp protein
powder along with Monica and raw cocoa
when it's just fucking fantastic shit
and it's super delicious and it's also a
very low in sugar.
It only has one gram of sugar per
serving.
It's because it's sweetened with Stevia,
which is a natural plant sweetener
that's really potent.
You only have to use like a tiny amount
of it.
It's pretty crazy shut,
but it's super delicious and nutritious.
And of course Alpha brain,
which is the cognitive enhancing
formula.
What Alpha brain is a.
it's common at atory supplement.
A bunch of different nootropics and
nootropics are these vitamins and
nutrients for the.
For Your Dome Son to file your neuro
transmitters to keep you talking.
All smoothies,
shit like me,
a use code name,
Rogan save 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
All right.
Freaks.
Oh,
alright.
death squad dot TV.
Go to [inaudible] dot TV and buy some t
shirts.
Ladies and gentlemen,
they're beautiful.
They feel good.
They make you feel better about yourself
and if you are alone at home and you're
like,
God,
I feel so lonely.
You put on your desk on a tee shirt you
like,
but I'm a part of a team and we were
going to be an avn Thursday.
We have a show at the hard rock and I
want to talk for you.
Hold up signs that I'll talk.
Brian as a strep,
so is in pain.
Every time he tells you.
Really show hard.
Rock in Vegas this Thursday.
It's Sam,
Tripoli.
Brian Red Band,
Doug Benson,
awful.
Doug band,
rouse.
Powerful.
Jason Rouse,
Jason Teebo.
Jason Tebow.
Powerful.
Jason t,
but that's a good damn.
If you're in Vegas,
you got to go.
If you're in there for the AVN,
you're already a fucking sick prek.
Okay.
You already know you got problems,
so it's a perfect job for you.
Okay.
Those were all sick.
No problem.
Just falling leak.
We got Julie Diaz and Duncan at the herb
or the Melrose Improv.
So if you live in Los Angeles.
Yeah.
So go to just go to [inaudible] dot TV
for the schedule of a very shows that we
put on.
It's not all the shows.
I mean,
you know,
Ari has his own shows.
Duncan has his own shows,
everybody has their own shows,
but you can kinda get a beat on.
We try to retweet each other's stuff as
much as possible for everybody.
Cool.
Awesome.
So desk while dot t dot v is the
website.
Um,
and uh,
uh,
my new specials available right now.
It's on Joe Rogan.net.
It's five bucks.
It's drm free.
It's just the,
the Louis C K model.
So I'm go get that and go fuck yourself.
Okay.
All right,
great.
Oop.
Joey or ladies,
you play the music and the podcast has
come full circle experience trying to
get podcasts all.
What happened?
He just,
he just died off there.
Like your,
your actual real voice.
The podcast has come full circle.
You are here.
If it was not for Opie and Anthony,
I doubt I would have ever thought it
would be so fun to do a podcast.
What was it about us that made you want
to do this?
Because you guys are the first radio
show that I've ever done.
That is a complete hang out.
Like almost every show that I had ever
done.
Even the great ones.
Howard Stern,
whatever it felt like they have an
agenda like the sit down and they'll ask
questions and you know,
they have and they're going to control
it and they're going to move it along
certain lines with you guys.
It was always just to hang out.
You would go there and it was just a
real conversation.
Well,
uh,
it's,
it's just that word lazy.
Yeah.
But you don't understand that all of a
sudden the right way to do it.
But then it became our thing,
you know,
just to chill out and,
go for it.
You guys doing it that way,
inspired me to do this the same way I
am.
That's so cool.
One hundred percent,
100 percent.
If it wasn't for doing your show because
every other show where someone got,
you know,
they got interviewed on your show.
You just talked.
I mean,
we could go on a show and you know,
we could just all ask anthony about guns
and that'd be a fascinating fucking show
and we could do it for an hour and a
half,
hour and a half.
You know what I'm saying?
That's him getting warmed up as far as
that'd be three or four hours,
but you know what I mean.
I mean it's like,
well,
the philosophy I've always had about
radio is a philosophy about radio.
Uh,
there's a lot of egos and radio.
Yeah.
And so they,
there's a lot of guys,
I don't feel like naming names today,
but a lot of guys,
they have to be the funniest guy in the,
in the room.
They have to be the most creative,
the most interesting.
And we took the tack,
like if you come on our show,
we're going to fucking sit back and
listen to what Joe Rogan has to say
because you come in well prepared and
you'll do,
you blow our mind every time you come
in.
But when I go home and I'm in among my
friends and family,
they go,
wow,
that was a really good show today.
I get the credit in the end.
So who gives a fuck?
Who the funniest guy is in the room or,
or the most interesting.
But a lot of radio guys never understood
that fucking concept.
So it goes back to your thought,
everything has to be all right for the
next 15 minutes we're going to do this
and then we're gonna move onto the
interview and if you get a laugh,
I got to make sure I get a bigger laugh.
That's an exhausting way to do it is
really dumb too.
It's like,
why would you not want other people to
be funny?
Right?
How does that make you less funny?
Like the idea that your entire body of
work that you've done up until now is
meaningless.
If this other person is funnier for a
brief moment.
Of course it's so stupid.
It's like,
why would you be even affected by it at
all if someone else is doing well,
but the business is filled with those
guys.
It's so weak.
It's comedy is as well.
Yeah.
And,
and they're scared of the unknown as far
as radio goes.
You know,
if something's going well just go with
it.
But they have that stupid a clock in
their head and they're like,
well,
we only allowed 20 minutes for this guy
to be funny or interesting and we got to
move on to like news or some horse.
Yeah.
I think you have to go to said,
just throw all that shit away and just
keep going.
All right.
We're going to read the news at noon.
You're fucking thing that you have to do
15 minutes and all that.
And that bored the hell out of me when I
got into radio.
I mean they still do it.
They still do it.
I got in and I was playing music and all
that shit.
I'm like,
this is stupid.
If I can't talk and just,
you know,
have some kind of hang,
then I'm going to go and do something
else.
Yeah.
Kevin.
And been a really interesting guys.
I don't know if you know them at all.
The guys,
of course.
Yeah.
Do you guys,
have you ever met one of them?
Who's the bigger guy that's been.
Yeah.
I've met Ben at k rock in New York.
He's really smart.
He could've been nicer,
really smart cats and if someone just
like let them talk in the morning and
just have people on talking and have
guests on a talk with them,
should be fucking a fantastic radio
show,
but they have to shove songs.
Then they just shove songs in it because
that's the new thing on regular radio.
You've got to get to music and for
whatever reason,
I mean,
and it's all music we've heard a million
times.
You're not going to blow my mind with a
new song.
Right.
And you can be in the middle of the
coolest fucking conversation.
They have to play a song and the PDS are
down the hall there.
They're watching the clock and they'll
hotline,
you know,
they'll,
they'll come march in the studio and
they'll do this point at an imaginary
watch like,
you know,
get back,
get back to the format.
So whack.
Hey,
am I going to get strep throat from you?
No,
no,
no.
He didn't.
I was only contagious for the.
First of all I'm thinking is I'm going
to get strep throat now.
I was,
how do you get strep throat then you
have to kiss somebody or something.
Uh,
I think it's from eating a lot of pussy.
I'm allergic to penicillin,
which is like the number one,
like get rid of strep things.
So that's why I get it so much.
You're that guy that's allergic it.
I'm the one
guy and it's so I have,
I think that's why I get it so much.
But the only thing I've been doing is
eating pussy.
What?
You sound like you're doing a character.
He's like,
yeah,
if you can,
if you didn't.
Pithy,
like the creepiest guy.
Every voice to be talking to Brian has
strep throat right now.
Your voice is whack.
If you took penicillin.
I need to know I get a huge rash over my
whole intensity.
It's pretty bad.
Rash.
I'm not like,
you can survive that,
right?
Yeah.
But I,
I can take z packs and that usually
works.
Love the zoo.
Pass time.
I love my left.
Tonsil is so big that the air is gone
from my throat.
Like when it tried to sleep,
it's like I'm gagging the whole night
because I'm like,
I can't breathe.
Oh,
rapid strep throat.
Think so it's not fun.
Oh,
this place is set up up to
Kinda intimidating,
intimidating.
Wait till we put the Werewolf in.
What's the world?
Will get a wearable.
There's a guy named.
Pat Mcgee is a special effects guy.
He's recreating the American Werewolf,
right?
You know,
uh,
American Werewolf in London.
They do a full size version of it.
And how bad ass is that kind of jealous.
We got just a shitty studio in New York
that we can't do much with.
Well,
that's the beautiful thing about not
having a boss,
you know,
to whatever we want.
We just set,
just done a little of that just a little
while.
You guys can,
you know,
you guys have been saddled down by
bosses forever if you guys,
uh,
not really.
Never.
Now we've never listened to him.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's caused a lot of strife over the
years.
But the fact that there's even any
strife,
you know,
they should just leave you the fuck
alone.
They should let you do whatever you want
to do and you're going to do it the
right way.
You're trying to do a good show as much
as we complain.
I mean,
we're allowed to do whatever the fuck we
want,
but what about.
What about this is ideal you have?
You don't listen to anybody?
No,
not no one is on your back.
This is the one there.
This is the whole operation.
Get it.
The whole operation.
Yeah.
We do whatever we want.
That's cool.
Yeah.
I mean there's a lot of shit that I'm
sure we would've gotten in trouble for
it.
We had to listen to somebody.
What do you think is stupid?
What is your number one thing you would
have gotten in trouble for?
If it was on regular radio?
You of the word cunt.
Oh,
language crap.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but satellite.
You can tell a lot of.
I'm sure a lot of corporate stuff,
but you guys know about corporations
drugs.
You wouldn't last a couple of sponsors,
but did you do any bits that would have
gotten you in trouble?
We don't really do.
Bits are going away.
Yeah,
we just,
I mean I would rather just have
conversations with interesting people
like it,
but then,
but every now and then someone will do a
bit.
That's fucking great.
I mean,
I'm not opposed to anybody creating
anything that's funny just for us to do
it.
So much to talk about.
Hope the world is fucking banana and I
do have to say this.
You're the king of twitter,
the King of twitter ads.
You are the king of twitter has to be
said.
You're the lengths you tweet or just
amazing.
Oh well get them to me.
You know,
most of your search that out.
Yeah.
Well maybe some of it is a things I
retweet.
Some of it is things Sunday,
whatever I could put,
but you're filtering it from,
you know,
you're filtering the shit you're,
you're finding and then sending it out
to your people,
but there's never been a time where you
get so much weird shit thrown at you all
day and you can throw it right back at
everybody.
And you were the one that started the
whole planet thing.
Where earth is this.
Yeah.
And then it shows this and it just gets
bigger and bigger and just blows your
mind.
Now the thing is everywhere.
But you were the first one to tweet
that.
Oh really?
Well,
it was just knowing how fucking big shit
is.
Loved that video.
That video is so fascinating.
Do you love it though?
It doesn't creep you out.
Yeah,
definitely.
Definitely does.
We had a neil degrasse Tyson Tyson on
the other day,
the astrophysicist.
Sure.
He was talking to us about.
Oh my God,
he was talking to us about the depth of
the universe and it just,
the way he does it,
first of all,
he's so brilliant and passionate and
when he describes things,
it's just so like there's like a theater
to it as well,
you know,
because he's such a good talker and he's
also so fucking smart.
So when he's talking about the
multiverse and the idea that the
universe with hundreds of billions of
galaxies,
like almost infinite,
is really just one of an infinite number
of universes and he likes,
it just freaks.
It can freak you the fuck out and you're
one of these guys.
You're convinces his life all over the
fucking place.
Right?
I don't see how weak,
you know,
I think they've done calculations on not
just like everything in the world is a
collection of Adam's essentially.
Right.
And I think if you understand what it is
that's your,
uh,
your Dorsal,
I think they understand that if the
universe is large enough that every
collection of atoms in exactly the same
collection as it is on earth will exist
somewhere else that when you're talking
about something that's infinite,
like literally everything that exists in
the exact same order and the exact
objects in the exact place exist in some
place,
but it has to be some insane light years
away.
Like 14 trillion,
trillion,
trillion trillion.
There was a into the wormhole with uh,
what's,
what's his name guys banging his
granddaughter,
Morgan Freeman,
Morgan Freeman.
And he's the host of this.
And it's just like.
So there's another ope.
It just,
you have to go far enough if that's what
infinity means.
It's so crazy that not only is there
another ope,
but there's another jamie in the room,
there's another Brian.
The room is another me and I wrote like,
that is real,
but what kind of life you think is out
there is that I think we're out exactly
how we're living on earth or it or is it
earth?
Uh,
5,000
years ago,
the universe infinite is so crazy that
the earth in exactly the order that it
appears here might be somewhere else
because it's just a combination of Adams
and various states and that combination
of animes in various states could
absolutely mirror in the infinite,
but we have to think about what the
infinite means,
what the with the infinite is.
It's impossible for us to conceptualize
that freak you out as a kid when you
started thinking about the universe and
then you were okay with the fact that,
wait,
maybe it ends and there's a wall.
This is how I thought of it.
I'm like,
okay.
The bar says,
and there's a wall,
but then I started thinking,
what the fuck's on the other side of the
wall?
I remember being a little kid and just
stopping and thinking for a second that
there's not a roof,
there's not a roof to the world.
Wow.
You know,
there's just kind of flying through
space and all of a sudden my law,
my world went like from my point of view
to be in this is my neighborhood,
this is where I lived,
to what the fuck?
Like how come nobody's talking about
that?
It was,
it was really weird to be like a seven
or an eight year old,
whatever it was when I really started
about eight.
I think it happens a around a for
everyone because that's about the time
you realize you're going to die your
life.
Far too scary day.
I remember I learned at eight that you
were going to die and my parents were
taken off to go to the movies.
I just want to suck on.
My Mom's was so fucking scared and to
them it was just a night out to me.
It was like a life changer.
I'm like,
wait a minute,
this fucking thing in day.
Yeah.
It was a weird,
weird night.
I cried the first night,
I realized that I was going to die
someday,
like six or something like that.
I cried.
I was really sad and that was also when
I was,
I,
I'd already given up on religion because
I did a year in Catholic school.
Are you a Catholic guy originally?
Yeah,
I did one year in Catholic school.
I was like,
yeah,
nope.
I'm telling my parents had run away from
home.
Was it?
I'm not going.
Was it all boys school?
No,
it was separate to separate us in class,
but there was girls that it would have
other classes.
I was,
I was brought up Catholic,
but I'm not a,
I'm not an organized religion guy.
The craziest girl I ever dated was,
went to an all girls Catholic school.
Yeah.
What do you believe in then?
Um,
I don't really believe in anything.
I mean,
I don't not believe in anything either.
That's the problem.
Are you an atheist?
No,
I wouldn't say I'm an atheist.
There's something right now we just
haven't.
I don't know.
I'm definitely not throw out the
possibility that there's something,
I think to throw out the possibility
that there's something out there is kind
of silly.
I think this,
a lot of the reaction that people do
that is the reaction against organized
religion and organized religion.
We all know is silly.
So your reaction is to say no.
There's no god.
There's no anything,
there's no evidence.
I,
I respectfully leave open the
possibility for almost anything.
But do you.
You said we all know,
we all know what the religion is
organized religion.
You're listening to this show and you,
you feel me on this dog.
I'm telling you know,
and I know that it's a crock of shit,
but that was,
that's interesting.
I want to go with that for a second.
Are you talking to the people out there
that go to church every Sunday?
They even know?
Or are you talking about the people that
have given up on,
on organized religion?
If you're really paying attention,
you know,
Tore Shit.
If you're really paying attention and if
you're not paying attention,
that's on you,
right?
You don't have.
People just don't want to admit that I
don't want it to themselves.
It doesn't mean that there's no god is
the idea that there's no god,
it's crazy,
but the real problem was the idea that
all those contradictory things,
all those ridiculous things that are
written down on paper about controlling
property and about wearing types of
cloth,
at the same time,
things need to be put to death for like
if you really knew what the fuck was in
the Bible and you really got a good
account of it and excellent translation
of all of it together,
which is really fucking difficult,
right?
You would go,
this is crazy.
People talk,
okay,
this is not God telling you all this
shit.
There may be a god and maybe God has a
way of communicating to you through good
and bad feelings,
good and bad reactions to people,
and maybe that's what God's message
truly is and that's people have sort of
learned lessons from these things and
written them down.
It doesn't discount the idea that there
might be some overwhelming force in the
universe that creates all of this.
The idea that we should discount that
entirely.
I think it's kind of nuts.
I think the problem is that it's been
simplified to this nonsense sort of
cartoonish,
you know,
man and a robe and gods and then his son
Jesus came down.
I think that that's what fucks it up for
the real idea because the real idea is
not that far fetched.
Well how do we update that?
Well,
yeah,
that's a good thing because the Bible
was written what,
600 years after the fact.
The real problem is pussy.
Okay,
let me just break it down.
The real problem is pussy because what
happens is someone has a new way of
thinking.
Someone has a new way of doing it.
Someone comes up with a new Bible and
they put it all together and then they
start teaching that shit and then they
start banging chicks and then everybody
gets pissed off and then everybody wants
to come in Waco style with guns and
you're not going to be able to update
it.
One of the things about religion is it
has to be old as fuck.
If it's not oldest,
fuck,
we're getting there.
We're not going to trust you,
but there was a time.
Catholicism wasn't old as fuck.
Yeah.
Was there one time it was as new as
scientology.
When was that?
When was it created?
Was it created all at once or did it
absorb other religions?
I don't.
I don't know.
The history of says I have no idea.
It just always was.
I wasn't paying attention.
What a country religion to grow up as a
Catholic was just fucking just torturous
and then and then the other religions
you gotta blow off as not being real.
Well,
everyone's full of shit.
Crazy.
That's the reality is that the absolute
hardcore reality is that we're just
studying some things that people wrote
and the idea that any of that stuff is a
message from God and then he's not
communicating with you today in some
way,
shape or form.
It's crazy.
You know?
I think that most of what people wrote
about,
most likely the origins of it,
the real big experiences that we wrote
about were either bullshit or would
probably psychedelic experiences.
I think they were eating a lot of
mushrooms back then.
The shit grew everywhere and they knew
the ones you could eat and the ones you
couldn't because it kept you alive.
You've talked about that on our show.
Yeah.
And,
and you look at the old,
uh,
what drawings and the drawings and
stuff,
and you see the fucking magic mushrooms.
All magic mushrooms,
first of all,
all over Christmas Lore,
all over depictions of Christmas is the,
to Mascara mushroom.
I mean you see little elves with like
dancing around these mushrooms.
So the thing about that mushroom is
apparently it was very variable,
like you could get ahold of some event
and it doesn't do shit for you and then
you can get a hold of some other stuff
that gives you the psychedelic
experience.
And it might be seasonal,
it might be geographical,
it might vary in genetics.
So it's a tricky mushroom,
but those are a lot of evidence that
points to the root of a lot of these
religious things having to do with
mushrooms and the use of psychedelic.
So why do they write about that one?
Because it's first of all,
find a deep on,
you could find it on the internet
somewhere deep,
but there have been people that have
written things about it,
but it's not something that makes people
excited.
The,
uh,
the idea of psychedelics being anything
other than a distraction and you know,
something bad for your life,
you know,
like when you think about,
like someone says,
oh,
he does psychedelics.
What does that mean to me?
It was,
it was to me,
you know,
automatically think hunter s Thompson,
he's losing his mind,
firing his gun at the walls.
You know,
that that sort of vision pops into mind.
Are you heading that way?
No,
that's crazy.
But if you,
if you said arguing the hunter s Thomas
of our time,
I heart,
that's ridiculous.
You're getting there.
And he was a genius.
He was a,
he was an alcoholic too.
I mean at the end it was really,
I'm a huge fan and the end of his life
is very sad.
I was listening to your uh,
yeah.
It was like almost he couldn't even
understand them.
Yeah.
He was just rambling and told.
Yeah,
I know you're not a big alcohol guy.
No,
because I'd listened to the Joe Rogan
podcast.
Who did you have on one of our.
Oh,
dom rare.
Powerful dot.
Yeah.
That was a cool plan partner.
I know and I found it fascinating that
you used to hang out at that pool joint.
Which one?
The north north of the city.
Chelsea.
Chelsea bulliers weren't in white
plains.
Yeah.
Executive leaders and wife was a great
podcast to a thanks.
Yeah,
totally.
The old stories of the old pool hall.
Yeah.
That's just one of the last fun places
where a man could be a man in this
country.
You know,
there's something about pool halls,
like a lot of people like they look down
on it or they have a negative
connotation with it because a lot of
times pool is thought of as like this
kind of tough person game or some,
you know,
you're going to be around like seedy
characters and.
But I've had some of the best times of
my life and pool halls.
Are you good?
Yeah,
I'm pretty good.
Real good.
Came in second place in the tournament
last night.
Oh,
you're still playing well.
Damn.
Yeah.
I played in Toronto.
Still like it.
Yeah.
I just started playing in a tournament
again.
But yeah,
I love playing.
I played,
I played a lot of money.
No,
no,
no.
I mean if I'm with somebody I would
gamble like a for the pay for the time
or something like that or play for like
20 bucks or something like that.
I not really interested in stealing the
money,
but I'm just interested in,
uh,
I just liked the game was just like
playing the game.
I like competing.
Why?
Why do you like that game?
Because it's a control game.
The game is all about focusing in
exactly on the amount of effort that you
have to use with your hand to make a
ball roll certain amount of revolutions
and there's times where literally you're
looking for the position to be,
to vary between one and maybe a half a
revolution.
So you're,
you're looking to get that close and
you're doing this all striking a ball
with another ball.
Now when I play,
I just want to try to hit that mark.
Have you ever seen anybody that's really
good?
Well,
yeah,
like really,
really good money.
SPN Yeah,
in real life,
but there's like an art.
What's her name?
Oh,
genetically she's very good.
She's good to look at.
There's there's guys that you watched
them play and it's like you're watching
an art form.
It's like,
I think that blows your mind when you
see that.
I think that's the case with anything.
I think if you understand chess,
I think that the chest is like that.
I think the people that really
understand shit.
I mean I understand chest,
but not enough to like read like the
Rook Knight to seven and all that shit.
I don't,
I don't really know it that way.
I just know which pieces go in what way,
but I know that peace to people that
love games,
they'll sit and watch a guy play and
they get an uber.
Ah.
When they see a good move,
like,
oh fuck yeah,
fuck.
Just it.
Just jacked him with that shit and that
you know that that comes from knowing
that that form of competition.
I,
I used to like playing chess,
I was pretty good growing up.
And then when you realize you have to
think 10,
12 fucking moves ahead.
It's a lot of work done,
a lot of work to think to think about
all these different things that could
possibly happen and to calculate what's
the risk and the reward and the factor
in how your opponent plays and what's
your.
What's your deal with alcohol?
What,
why don't you like it as much as the
other stuff you've talked about?
Oh,
it's fun.
It's just bad for your body.
You know,
like still.
I still drank.
I mean I'll help.
I'll have a couple of cocktails on
occasion,
on occasion,
but the problem is like get hammered.
Then the next day you feel like fucking
shit,
but if you smoke pot you don't feel bad
at all.
You know?
Alcohol does a lot of great things.
It,
it,
it enables people to laugh when they
maybe wouldn't have a lot more fucking
high five and a lot more craziness.
This could be great.
Loosens people up.
Yeah.
It's great for comedy clubs,
man.
Like you could tell like evenings a
week,
nights at the Improv,
like one of the things about the Improv
during the week,
uh,
the shows are great.
They're very realistic.
Like the crowds do not give you any more
than you deserve.
If you're,
you're,
you're killing.
They'll laugh really hard.
Sure.
But you gotta be on point.
They're not going to just give it to
you.
Yeah.
They're not drinking.
You look around,
you'll see like,
ah,
sodas and shit.
You know,
I just got a text from Jamie from the
Improv by the.
Well I flew in.
You mean the laugh factory?
Oh,
he's left factor by the.
I'm not the Improv.
This other club on the other side of
town,
but he writes opioid ladies and
gentlemen.
Sorry.
Lost my phone.
You are welcome to come anytime.
I wrote him two nights ago when I come
to town,
like going to the comedy store or you
know,
any of the places.
That's where we first met.
Yes.
Yeah.
We first met before ever.
Did you show?
We met at the comments,
you don't always ask me why I love Joe
Rogan so much and uh,
when we were going through our shit for
the sex and the church thing,
you like stepped out and wrote a fucking
article on the whole damn thing
supporting us.
Yeah,
I was,
I was horrified that no one was getting
upset that you guys were getting.
Oh,
everyone was getting upset.
But I mean,
you know what I mean.
It wasn't like,
it wasn't like a national free speech.
Outraged man.
You wrote a great article and that's
when I started really realizing,
you know what you're all about,
you know,
because I knew it for fear factory.
I didn't even know that you're a standup
at that.
At that time we didn't know each other.
And then when I saw your standup I was
absolutely blown away because,
you know,
you leave thinking about shit.
I liked that.
I liked that from a standup,
but I'm full time.
What was going to say?
Oh,
um,
there was no outrage because we didn't
have the social networking like our fan
base was.
They were out of their minds.
Like what do you mean you guys are
getting kicked off the air,
but there was no twitter back then.
There was nothing.
So it's kind of like,
I guess we've said on our show a bunch
of times,
you know,
you hit your kick it and hill and all
the ants go fucking scurrying,
but they don't know what the fuck to do
that.
That was our fan base.
They're all pissed off.
They were running,
you know,
all sorts of directions,
but they,
they couldn't organize.
Nowadays you can organize obviously.
I thought it was the most ridiculous
shit ever.
The people were making a great outrage
about the fact that someone had sex in a
church that it's like you did something
so horrible,
man.
They did something that everybody wants
to do,
but they didn't.
The super secret special place.
And when Magic House,
why's it bad?
They're not bad.
They're,
it's stupid.
Why would it be worse if someone fucked
in a supermarket?
That was my point.
It would be,
I would think would be worse with
someone at a toys r us.
Yeah.
No,
I get your point,
but what would be the answer to why is
it bad in the church?
Is that disrespectful?
It's a magic house.
That's what they're saying.
You know what I'm saying?
That magic is real.
And then all this fucking corny bullshit
that's obviously not real,
you know,
really look these people with their
stain glasses and there's a dude is
being tortured to death and he's
supposed to stare at that and feel bad.
And I was in the vestibule anyway so I
don't even think it was in the actual
church and to this day I don't even know
if they actually did it cost me two and
a half years of my career.
And you were one of the groups.
I mean literally one of the only guys
stepping forward.
It was so gross.
I couldn't believe it was real.
I couldn't believe you guys are getting
fired for that and I just,
I just like,
this is the craziest thing I've ever
heard.
Like if we don't stand up and say this
is nothing,
this is not that big a deal,
why are you making a big deal out of it?
Not only that,
it's,
it's funny.
It is funny,
you know that if they,
if they did it anywhere else,
would you have gotten in trouble?
That's the real question.
They did it a lot of other places that
day,
but that didn't get you in trouble.
They don't even talk about the church
that got you in trouble.
So that's really saying that there's
like a public policy.
Well,
the magic place Israel.
Well here's the thing,
the same day it was done in a toys r us.
That's right.
Yeah,
that's right.
Is Right about that.
So it was a toy store and the church
were the two biggies that day,
but they didn't care about the fact that
they did Schwartz,
one of those,
I think it might've been Fao Schwarz,
the fact that that the reinforcing the
idea that this magic place is actually a
magic place.
Yeah.
It's really kind of creepy that people
go there and they'd want to worship and
then want to be like,
you know,
so like if they interrupted and certain
[inaudible] and a bunch of people and in
front of a bunch of people,
but if no one knows about it,
they actually pulled it off and I didn't
get caught.
Right.
No.
See,
no.
There was a security guard that saw it
and actually he basically said,
get the hell out of here.
I don't want to deal with this shit.
And then someone grandstand of that day
and you know,
it got.
So the only person that saw it was a
security guard.
That was it.
We were,
we were done.
We were good.
He saw and he didn't want to deal with
it.
He didn't want to write it up.
He didn't want to call anyone and then
someone grand standard.
And then the guy basically it was like,
all right,
fine,
if this is what you want.
And then next thing you know,
the cops got called wow.
It was so real.
We had a chance that we would have got
away with it and then we would have went
to our bosses like that,
man.
Then I,
we're just making belief.
It's just so silly.
But that fucked us up,
man.
We've,
we've never come back from.
That was so fucking big.
Yeah.
You guys were gigantic.
Fuck.
And then the world changed by the time
we got back.
Yeah.
Two and a half fucking years.
Two and a half years.
Isn't it funny that,
you know,
people get addicted to other shows.
They just like,
whoa.
They lock onto a show and then they just
get a.
They get into it.
If you take it away from them for a
couple of years,
things changed.
Well,
they came back,
but I mean,
you know,
then we're competing with everything
else.
Yeah.
You know,
to this.
Now look,
everyone's podcasting,
everyone's on their phones,
you know,
now you're competing with some idiot
that just wants to look at tweets all
day.
So I try to get their attachment.
Could you have done podcasting at that
point existed?
No.
Nothing?
There was nothing to do.
We had a wait.
They actually paid up and pee.
You Go pee.
Yeah.
But do you love doing this?
You know,
someone took this away from you for two
and a half years or the UFC for two and
a half years,
but they were paying you.
Would you be cool with that Joe Rogan?
No,
I'd be sad.
And plus the fact that I,
I knew that another company would hire
us,
you know,
uh,
immediately to continue where we were.
Yeah.
You would have immediately gotten.
But our company said,
fuck that.
We're paying every single dollar,
but you can't do nothing.
That's so gross.
What a Shitty fucking company policy.
So I tried to get out of my contract at
the time,
but my agent was a little scared because
he was getting his piece.
He was getting his taste.
So I'm like,
oh,
we'll get this whole fucking thing back
together.
Oh,
that's so yucky.
That's a contract.
Conflict of interest isn't.
I mean we're making,
doing something that we're making good
money.
And he was getting his 10 percent.
Yeah,
that's a conflict.
Why would,
why would he call the company and go,
Hey,
you know,
my boys went out,
but I'd call them like weekly.
I'm like,
get the fuck out of this contract.
Because at the time clear chow was the
big radio company.
They want us immediately,
they wanted to put us on a q and a for
New York.
So what,
what,
you know,
what did they want money to get a payoff
to get you out of the contract?
Did they or would you have had to just
take a chance?
I had sued.
I um,
wait,
what was that again?
Because I had a flip there.
Oh,
it was.
I said why would they want money?
Like it was the company that don't.
Who owns you guys?
It was CBS,
CBS,
xfinity product.
They have accepted money to get out of
that,
you know,
you know.
So how could you say people get to say
you're full of Shit,
but I know it says I know this to be
true.
They didn't want us to compete with
Howard.
Uh,
because they knew we'd go across the
street,
do mornings.
Would we beat Howard stern warnings?
I don't know,
I would like to think we'd have a pretty
good shot at back then especially.
And uh,
they were killing it.
We worked in this fucking huge and,
and afternoons they knew at the very
least we're going to take a,
you know,
a nice chunk of his audience away and
that,
that was a lot of money to the company.
So they sat down in a board room and
they said,
look,
it's better that we pay these fucking
guys for two and a half years instead of
taking the chance them going up against
our main guy.
That is a fact.
Well,
if that's the case,
you know,
if they probably looked at their own
profits and how much it would cost to
pay you off,
they probably figured it was worth the
gamble.
Oh No.
They made everything.
They made way more money us.
That's how weird.
That's how fucked up the business was so
strained as they used to.
They used to talk about it.
It was a business where,
you know,
where you just printed up money.
They just printed up money and what the
advertisers were.
We're just paying a fucking lot of money
for their ads.
How much has the radio business changed
since the Internet?
Uh,
drastically.
Massively,
right?
Yeah.
They're stupid because at,
at the time you need personality driven
radio.
They,
they said fuck that.
So the two biggest formats on regular
radio is sports talk,
which anyone could do.
No offense those guys.
But you know,
that stuff is easy to study and then
it's a pop music.
That's it.
No talk shows are left.
Really?
Yeah.
It's hard.
You were saying earlier,
Kevin being they have to,
they have to play their music now too.
I think they've always done it that way.
You think?
Thanks.
I feel like I remember a time where they
were street talk show,
but you know,
they're,
they're good dudes.
I,
I just think that the future is not
looking good for like regular radio
company.
Their model that they operated under.
It's just really deteriorated.
Right?
There's too many options
and we'll like stitcher and your car.
You could listen to this podcast anytime
you won your car.
Just set that up and bang.
Yeah.
You download them and put it on your
phone.
You can get them all off itunes.
I got it right here.
So easy to do.
It's really hard for a radio station to
compete that,
especially if they have the wacky dj
voice.
You guys are one of the first to shit
all over the place.
You really made it obvious,
you know,
and then there was obvious to everyone.
It is obvious to everyone,
but nobody brings it up.
One of my favorite bits we do every year
is that Jack Tobar bit.
Yeah.
I love that.
So many radio shows are so fucking
pissed off at us,
but it's like you look at yourselves,
we're actually trying to help you out.
Why are you still doing that type of
radio?
October.
So October.
We just,
uh,
we feature one show every day for the
month of October.
Just beat the shit out of them,
but they're all doing the same thing.
You know,
there's,
there's shows that they have to have a
woman,
which we call the whole obviously,
but that's a DM program director.
They get like,
they would get like youtube together,
right.
And then they would throw a woman and
for her point of view,
yeah,
I'm not really interested.
Course,
it's not that I'm a misogynist,
but I am a man talking to men and they
have a to women too.
They have a tendency to fucking put up
the yield sign or the stop sign like,
Oh,
you know,
knock it off.
So yeah,
I mean we've been.
So we've been offered females over the
years and we just said,
hell fucking no.
I mean we'll have females on our show to
do well,
you know,
they do really well.
They could,
they could hold their own,
but to have someone in there on a
regular basis,
oh,
that would be a fucking nightmare.
I mean,
you'd have to have the perfect mix of
personalities because otherwise there's.
Look,
there's nothing wrong with women like.
But what women like and men like is
varies drastically big fucking
difference.
And when women are in the mix,
if you're trying to do anything,
especially something creative along
these lines,
when it's,
uh,
it's like freeform conversational type
shit.
If a woman is in the mix on a regular
basis,
it changes the entire dynamic of the
show.
Are you going to watch and everything
you're saying?
Yeah.
You gotTa Watch everything you're saying
and to try not to be as rude.
No.
All right.
Yeah.
You gotta you gotta definitely not shit
on her.
The way you should on each other.
You're going to be very aware of.
You can't talk shit to check the way you
could tell it like you just say the
French shut up stupid.
No,
and that's fine,
but no one ever gets upset.
But if you say that to a girl,
shut up stupid like,
eh.
I think our female listeners understand
that too,
because they're like,
wait,
we get to hear like guys unfiltered.
Yes.
Because you know the guys in their
lives,
they're around their wives or their
girlfriends.
They're not unfiltered.
So radio shows like yourself and ours,
you know,
they,
they like to kind of take that peak and
listen to it.
Yeah.
That's the only opportunity they can.
Just like when me,
when I listened to out cute gay radio,
I don't listen.
That's the only way I don't ever hear
that gay people have like conversations.
Is it good?
I really don't know.
They're nice guys know hall,
but there's um,
I guess I guess I check them out.
I just get a kick out of.
I get a kick out of listening to
everything.
I like listening to conservative talk
radio.
I like listening to like those really
silly conservative guys where everything
is fucking 100 percent.
It's Joe's.
Yeah.
Down the road.
Well he's,
he's little weirder.
Alex has a lot of shit in there.
Like he thinks marijuana should be
legal.
Gay Marriage should be legal.
He's just a conspiracy theorists to the.
You scared me for awhile because I'm
like,
man,
Joe Rogan is a really smart dude.
And you were really into the Alex Jones
and I miss.
Hold on,
I misread it.
And we finally had that conversation and
you,
you said it,
you're like,
I believe.
What 20 percent did you say?
Like it depends.
It depends on the subject.
Sometimes I believe 70 to 80 percent of
the way it says.
Fair enough.
Because the last time he was on our
show,
I was surprised how much I was taking
what he was saying.
But then there's been other times it's
been ridiculous.
It's crazy,
but he's awesome and fun to listen.
Do It's an act.
No,
I know him really well.
It's not an act.
He's my friend,
but I've,
I've.
I've known that guy for over 10 years
now.
Alex Jones is exactly who he presented.
I can.
You're not going to give me the total.
No,
no,
no.
I'm telling you.
I'm telling you this,
that he.
He understands conspiracy,
like living in that world is as good for
his business.
So he,
he forces some of this shit to continue
to live in the conspiracy world.
I,
I understand why you would see that,
but I don't believe it's that what I
believe it is more of it's confirmation
bias that happens when someone gets
really fixated on the idea that there's
a conspiracy everywhere.
So they start seeing conspiracies in
places that they're not right,
but it doesn't mean that the validity of
some of the shit he's brought up,
the validity of some of the shit he's
brought up was unquestionable.
Right now.
There's a lot of stuff that he brings
up.
And by the way,
he was bringing it up way ahead of
anybody else he was,
he was talking about he during the first
days of September 11th,
he was calling it a false flag attack.
And he was saying that,
um,
you know,
there was a,
there was possible that,
you know,
buildings were detonated and like he was
sticking himself way,
way,
way out on a limb.
And when he did that,
I was like,
wow man,
you can't.
I was like,
you can't say that.
That's crazy.
You can't,
you know,
you can't,
you can't say that they're willing to go
to war for profit.
I thought he was being nuts.
I was talking to him.
I was like,
you know,
you're just drawing all these
conclusions,
but next thing you know,
we're at war with Iraq and nobody
understands why.
And you know,
he's saying it's for profiteering,
they're profiteering over there.
Right?
I don't believe that he's right about
like September 11th being orchestrated
by the government.
I don't think it was orchestrated by the
government,
but I do think that capitalized.
Well,
of course.
I mean,
one of my thoughts on that is if you
want,
let's say you want to bring your country
to war,
right?
And you know that there's some shit that
could be going down in New York City
like planes going into the fucking
buildings,
you know,
that would be technically really good
for the country because then you would,
like you said profiteer and,
and,
uh,
head off to war.
Why when you let it just happen.
Well,
one of them was,
that's where,
that's where I'm,
that's where my line is,
where I wonder in that it's like a gray
area to me,
but to,
to think that,
you know,
people were wiring the buildings while
people were going in and out of work.
That's just ridiculous.
Yeah.
I put them possibly let things happen
and go,
you know what?
All right,
we know this is going down,
but you know,
it's not the worst thing for what our
agenda right now.
It's possible.
The real issue is the idea of the false
flag and the idea of the false flag is
the idea that the government would plan
out a fake attack,
would they do that?
And for most people that answer's no,
no.
Most people say the government would
never do that,
but the real problem is they've done it.
They really actually have done it.
Not only have they done it,
they've planned on doing it a bunch of,
other times they couldn't pull it off.
There was one from when the Bush
administration was leaving.
They were talking about in 2007,
I believe it was.
They were talking about,
uh,
going into,
Iran and coming up with a false flag
attack and in order to get us into war
with Iran before the administration was
to set the,
you know,
the next administration has said Obama
Administration into some crazy fucking
war that he couldn't control.
Now in the end,
is that good for the country in their
minds?
I know,
I think it's profiteering.
I really do.
I think there's any other of your
buddies,
right?
There's no other way and it has nothing
to do with actually make the country
stronger in the end.
If you can't justify it militarily,
if you can't justify the reason why
you're there,
then you profiteering and you know,
it's just,
it's really that simple.
It's like someone profiting amps Fuckin
lutely.
Okay,
so you can't justify when you're there
and someone's profiting.
That means it's about the profit and
that's something that we don't like to
hear.
We don't.
We,
we don't like to accept that shit in
this country.
And Alex Jones,
Patriotic Alex Jones brings up all that
shit.
The northwoods document and the
northwest documentaries in the 19
sixties,
1962,
I think it was before Kennedy was
assassinated.
They saw the joint chiefs of Staffs
Sinus.
They agreed on this.
They were going to fake a bunch of
attacks on America by the Cubans.
They were going to blow up a drone jet.
They're going to take a jet flight in
the air with radio control.
Then blow it up in the sky.
They're going to blame it on the cube
and said,
we're going to arm a Cuban friendlies in
there.
We're going to lob mortars at
Guantanamo,
Bang,
possibly killing American civilians or
citizens rather,
and they were going to do all this so
that we would get angry and we would
want to go to war with Cuba because the
only way we could get to go to war with
Cuba,
they wrote all this down.
They're like,
we're good to go.
Then I'm not.
Kennedy was like,
get the fuck Outta here with this.
Kennedy vetoed it.
Where were you at Kennedy?
But he said they killed them.
I'm almost positive.
I quite a few people.
It was quite a few people wanted that
guy.
What's his name?
Came out what?
A couple days ago,
right?
Robert Kennedy's kid and them wanted to
do it.
No,
he said there's definitely.
You know that that was definitely a
conspiracy.
I don't think there's any question.
I mean,
I think there's a lot of people that
want to tie things up in a neat little
packages.
I think that's the least tie.
A little neat little package on earth.
I really don't,
just the video alone,
there's a prude or video.
The fact that you know that they had to
attribute all those wounds to one bullet
because they found a bullet that hit an
underpass and ricocheted and so they
were like,
they were coming up with a logical
reasons why all these wounds.
It's kind of from three shots.
It's kind of insulting our intelligence,
right?
Yeah.
Why would they say why would they limit
it to three shots?
Because I was the only amount feasible
for this guy to pull off course to make,
to make it.
One guy had to be no more than three
shots and it doesn't mean Lee Harvey
Oswald wasn't in on it.
I don't know.
He could have been.
What the fuck it been.
He had a long history with the CIA.
Had a long history of being,
living Russia,
possibly being a Russian spy mean we
with.
There's a lot that points to the fact
that Lee Harvey Oswald was doing some
shady shit to.
You ever been to Dealey Plaza?
Yeah,
I've been there.
Have you been.
There were.
No,
those whack jobs come out,
but their books and their card tables.
No,
there's still reliving.
Oh,
the day.
And they all have something to sell.
Oh,
you haven't seen that?
No,
I drove through it.
No Man.
Next time you,
you played Dallas,
you have to go to Dealey Plaza and you
have to hang out there for like three or
four hours.
Well,
we drove through it and it's so weird
piece of history.
It's smaller than.
Yeah,
it's tiny and it,
it,
it looks like,
um,
it looks like a Hollywood stage,
right?
It looks like a set for a movie because
nothing has really changed.
I mean the trees have grown.
That's about it.
But these people that were there that
day,
they're all.
You talk about profiteering to this day.
They're profitero and they go there
everyday and try to sell their pamphlet
or their book or,
or whatever the fuck it.
Someone like you,
you would love it.
Love that.
Sandy Hook,
uh,
fully exposed video that's been
announced.
I saw that they tried to say it's a
conspiracy conspiracy.
Like how,
you know,
like there was two other shooters and
they show like even footage that like
the news of people like,
like the police catching a guy in the
woods and then whatever happened to that
guy and have some of the kids.
So did the police catch him or not?
Can't they just talked to the police or
the policing on it as well?
Well,
I'm waiting for somebody to debunk that.
I've seen the videos.
I'm like,
something's got to be wrong here.
They were saying that the tribute video
was put up a month in advance and I was
like,
how do you know that someone did just
edit something and write it up?
Another video I like.
It could've been a post that was made a
month ago.
They did something else and they just
took out the stuff and put it.
The regular video in that could have
been at.
There's ways to like fake a timestamp if
you ever,
you know,
previous posts of your editing.
I don't know whether or not that's real,
but I,
I do know that whenever anything happens
now,
a million people for conspiracy,
even if it doesn't make any sense,
even though there's no conspiracy,
I love a good conspiracy of love.
A good guy.
We grew up with that shit.
Do you believe the,
uh,
a big foot.
That's a good one,
man.
I'm really.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
This is the reason why.
Two reasons.
One then was going to ask you about
blackness,
which is on the same page.
We get Jane Goodall,
who's a world famous primatologist she
believes in big five.
No.
Yeah.
One hundred percent.
She says she's convinced that there's an
undiscovered primate [inaudible].
I'm pretty sure that's her exact words.
She's convinced.
So there's an undiscovered primate
living in the Pacific northwest.
So we're.
The fuckers is the remains.
Well,
the deal is,
well,
you know,
we had a hunter on yesterday.
This Guy Steven Rinella,
and we were talking about animals like,
has he ever seen a dead mountain lion?
No,
never seen a dead mountain lion.
You know,
you could.
And he's a hunter.
He's in the woods constantly.
We know mountain lions are real,
but what are the odds of running around
and finding it dead?
One it.
It's pretty fucking small,
but no one has found a skeleton.
Skeletal remains and nothing.
Nothing credible.
But Mountain Lion?
No,
no,
no.
I'm talking about for bigfoot.
Okay.
Yeah,
but I'm saying I know that,
but the reason why Jane Goodall believes
that it might be a real animal is
because there was a real animal that
looked just like that and it lived
alongside people.
It's called gigantic Pythagoras and the
photos of them are kind of crazy.
Like they have a recreation at one,
but it's an eight foot tall bipedal
giant sasquatch.
I mean,
that's really what it is.
But they have actual proof that it
lives.
Oh,
he lived.
Yeah,
he lived 100 years ago because they have
bones.
Oh,
they do updates that someone was talking
about.
I believe that that actually was one of
the few primates that stores.
It's dead.
Like they buried their dead.
They had like,
they're dead in one area.
Right?
So they think they,
you know,
they might've understood life and death
more than other chimps who just sort of
leave their monkey bodies laying around
after they die,
you know,
they took care of the bodies,
which is really kind of freaky.
And if they were really,
really smart and multiple,
all primates are smart,
you know,
they're all reasonably smart because it
was a gigantic one.
Does that big?
It could be smart as fuck,
but I mean everyone's searching for it
now.
Who searching or,
you know,
I don't know anybody.
I just feel like I could say that.
Say that it's true.
You don't think like people.
I mean that would be amazing for
somebody if they could prove that
bigfoot know spike has a new show.
It's like a $10,000,000
challenge or something crazy like that
to find big for my.
I think I have said too much money,
so don't blame me.
It might not be 10 million or whatever
it is.
There's a lot of money to go find big
foot and it's a good concept.
Yeah,
it's a fucking great concept.
You know,
and you got to go deep into the woods
and look for something.
The only guy that I've ever heard tell a
big foot store.
I heard him tell it on your show and
then he came and told it on my podcast.
It was Les Stroud,
survivor man,
right.
His,
his big foot story was a pretty credible
because that guy,
what did he say?
Yes,
he was.
He had to,
to um,
different encounters.
One of 'em he was in Alaska and this is
the most memorable and he was in his
tent and sleeping and it was just lying
in his tent trying to go to sleep.
And he heard thumping through the woods
by Peta lease and it was walking on two
legs clearly.
And he goes and it was really heavy.
You could tell it was really heavy and
he didn't know what to do.
So he just laid there and waited and it
got closer to him and it was coming
towards his camp and he said it was
about 50 feet from him.
It started
both
like he goes clear primate,
sounds like clear primate sounds.
And he goes and reaches for his camera
and when he rustles the thing runs off
and the thing runs off.
He says,
it's running on two legs.
I hear it.
Thump,
thump,
thump.
Fuck.
10.
You know,
and he to this day,
is he?
He's convinced that it was a bear.
He said there's no way that was a
fucking bear.
There's no way it.
I know I've been around every animal,
you know,
he's a real survivalist.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that guy goes out there with the
fucking pocket life and it can last a
month.
Where it was he who is in Alaska.
Oh,
you said he was hundreds of miles from
anybody to do.
They follow him in on a plane for hours
before they dropped him off for a week
and he runs into this fucking animal out
there.
There's been a lot of sightings in,
in Alaska by the way.
It's not just one.
There's hundreds of bigfoot sightings
and Alaska.
We got to catch one though.
Yeah,
we do too.
Are you scared of the woods?
Fuck.
You should be scared of the woods.
Fucking scared.
She'd be scared of everything,
everything natural because then you
become a part of the food chain here.
When a studio,
the beautiful thing about the studio,
we have eliminated the food chain 100
percent.
It's just us in a fucking table and
yeah,
you don't have to like look out for
Jaguars and shit.
If you live somewhere that sucked,
you'd have to look out for Jaguars.
Well,
you know when you're going into the
jungle,
are you going into the woods?
It's a beautiful thing,
you know,
to be with nature.
It's beautiful,
but you also agree to be a part of
nature.
You throw yourself back into the
lottery,
right?
You know,
and it's fun for the first couple of
minutes and then you start seeing those
shadows and fucking mind plays tricks on
you.
I was in Montana.
I went hunting for a week.
That's cool.
Yeah.
We went with the.
Steve Rinella was on yesterday.
I shot this thing.
Woops.
Wait,
you shot this thing?
Yeah,
I shot this thing.
What is it?
That's a deer.
That's a nice,
uh,
how many points?
Eight a point.
Fucking deer we're looking at right now.
Just the skull and the antlers.
It was a interesting experience.
But to um,
to camp out like five nights in a,
in,
you know,
like this really wild habitat like that
man,
you really,
you start looking around for stuff.
You really keep up.
We found Mountain Lion Shit,
right?
That was a real eyeopener.
Like you see a big fat rope of shit with
hair it and you're like,
okay,
something killed a deer with its face.
Jesus.
It caught a deer and killed it with its
face.
It's hanging out here,
dropping shits.
So how did,
how did you know you were safe?
Well,
we had rifles.
Now at night when you're sleeping,
well,
you're in a tent.
You know,
it's gonna know where to attack in the
tent.
It looks at a 10.
It's this big thing that doesn't totally
understand they,
when they smell,
if you have food in the Tan or something
like that,
especially bears,
it can get really tricky.
But there's no bears in this area.
Like mountain lions are really
scavengers.
They're looking to kill things.
I got to ask you,
so how is it a to kill Salta?
It's not that hard.
No.
You're all right with that.
Yeah.
I'm fine with that because I've been
eating meat my whole life and if you
don't kill them,
it's not like they live forever.
You know what you're doing is you're,
you're ending their life in you.
You're,
you're choosing to end their life.
But their life is very temporary.
It's very temporary in a very harsh
climate.
And if you don't do it,
they get eaten by wolves.
Now I'm not questioning that.
I just don't think I could do it.
You can do it.
Of course you could.
Your,
your personal.
You want to be alive.
Let me tell you something.
You're a father.
Does it bother you at all though?
No,
not even a little bit.
No.
I mean,
I have respect for it.
I have reverence for the animal.
I mean it was,
uh,
you know,
seeing an animal in the wild like that
is,
you know,
I don't want to use the word majestic,
but it's a,
it's a really powerful moment.
Like you see that animal like wild,
like it's probably never seen a human
being before we were in the bad lands in
Montana and you're,
you're running into a deer that very
likely is,
you know,
three years old,
two,
and I never,
never seen a person ever.
And then you're sneaking up on them and
shoot them.
You know,
it's pretty intense,
but the food is delicious.
It's really nutritious and healthy.
And if you're a person who eats animal
protein,
I can understand the ethics behind,
uh,
not wanting to cause harm to animals,
not wanting to kill them,
but especially in the case of big game
hunting like deer,
all you're doing is you're,
you're ending their life before a
Predator takes them out.
They all get taken out,
but they get taken out and I know
they're over populated.
All,
you know,
how many deer die of old age?
Zero,
zero.
Literally zero.
They're just fucking making babies.
Wolves are pulling the babies out of the
Mamas Pussy while they're giving birth.
I mean,
there's a crazy life.
You're out there in the woods is fucked
up podcast.
It's as dark as it gets out there in the
dear world,
so when you come along and blow their
heart out with a bullet,
I'll have to try it.
Then.
It's really like the safest.
I mean not the safest.
It's the most humane way for them to die
ever.
You know,
it's.
I could understand people's points of
view,
like if you want to be a Vegan,
if you want to be a vegetarian,
you don't want to cause any harm.
I,
I totally understand that,
but I think if you do accept that most
people eat meat and that is the case in
this culture.
Most people eat meat.
This is the most humane way to acquire
the meat and all you're doing is acting
as a Predator in a world filled with
predators.
You're not denying any other animal the
predation,
and in fact the idea is that if done
correctly,
it keeps the animal populations healthy.
Silicon fucking starve to death.
I understand all that.
I'm just thinking of what goes on in
your head.
That's.
No,
it didn't.
I was ready for it.
I had prepared myself for it for a long
time,
so I wanted to do this the first time.
Yeah,
the shots.
Yeah.
Wow.
Cool.
You know,
and it's not like,
um,
it's a very respectful thing.
I mean,
you're eating,
I'm eating on this whole animal,
you know,
it takes months to eat it.
There's a lot of meat.
Yeah.
It's processed and cut.
And I lived in western New York.
We had a lot of venison.
Chili.
Oh yeah.
I didn't like it.
Western New York is a lot of fucking
deer.
No Shit.
When you take that ride from buffalo to
long island where I brought,
you know,
I was uh,
brought up all we used to count how many
dead deer on the top of the cars.
Yeah.
You see a lot of hundreds.
Because,
you know,
especially during hunting season and all
that,
and then on the side of the road and all
that crap,
a lot of people get their cars fucked up
by those deer to.
Yeah.
That's why it's very important to keep
deer populations down.
Like people don't understand.
Like if,
if gear populations get really big,
first of all,
you got a lot of lyme disease as well,
that,
that happens to ticks travel from deer
to deer and they get into people and you
know,
lyme disease and people's fucking
devastating to your health.
Right.
And a lot of that is overpopulation,
is these fucking deer.
They get,
I mean,
they can get,
there's a,
a road from Massachusetts,
western Massachusetts to uh,
New York to like the White Plains area.
I forget what the road it is probably a,
I want to say [inaudible] 91 maybe.
Whatever it is.
There's a,
it's a two lane road.
No,
at one point when you're like,
I'm not too late.
Two lanes on each side for later.
I guess a way way up in the upstate
Massachusetts in western Massachusetts
as you're driving down in New York,
it gets so bad with deer that you got to
go like 20 miles an hour.
It's fucking crazy.
They're just darting out in front of the
lights,
just running out in front of your car.
You ever see when get hit by a car?
Yeah,
yeah,
I've seen like fuck up.
It's pretty fucked up.
Yeah.
I've seen a bunch of them on the side of
the road,
you know,
in boulder.
It's weird.
They're not scared of cars at all.
They don't even run.
They just stand there.
Really?
Yeah.
Boulder.
There was a deer.
We parked the car,
got out,
the deer was 20 feet away,
20 feet away and we're all just standing
there looking at them and there's like,
Hey,
what the fuck you bitches looking at it
and it just keeps eating this grass.
It was just used to it.
They're so used to it.
It was just used to cars.
We took a picture of him and got back in
the car and he jumped across the fence.
I haven't run out,
but they get used to people and you
know,
if you don't keep those populations
down,
they're going to be slamming into your
cars at night and they're like little
crazy squirrels,
you know,
but they'll kill you.
Like they'll go through your windshield.
No kidding.
Have you ever seen those photos online?
Have giant through the,
through the windshield,
but they're beautiful.
I understand that.
Beautiful.
I'm not saying we should eradicate them,
but we should eat them.
You know,
there's nothing wrong with the eating
them.
There's plenty of them.
I was just trying to get into your head.
Oh,
I was just curious because I've never
done it.
That's all.
Well,
I never did it until this time and I
wondered whether or not I was going to
have a problem with it.
But uh,
I eat meat.
I've always eaten meat.
I like it.
It's delicious.
Of course it would be hypocritical.
It's one of my favorite foods in the
world.
Which one?
Snake snakes?
Yeah.
He just love it.
Steak over misskey.
Misskey lump charcoal and salt and
pepper.
Bitch.
And throw it out there.
Do you go with the grass fed?
Do you ever have the grass fed is
terrific.
It's fucking beef.
Yes.
Very nice.
Really good.
It's interesting.
It's a different kind of taste and it's
way better for your body to.
What are you drinking over there?
Step bulletproof coffee shit that I told
you about,
but it's made with butter.
Yes.
It's made with grass fed butter.
What do you learn about this shit?
This is a guy named Dave asprey who came
onto Brian,
tells me everything.
He's my,
he's my Yoda.
Brian knows this shit.
No,
it's like Yoda,
Yoda,
like pretending to be stupid background
with all the brightest.
One point on my strengths,
the um,
this guy,
uh,
that we had on the podcast,
Dave Asprey,
he,
uh,
gave us a really fascinating speech
about Mycotoxins,
some that I wasn't aware of,
but most coffee when you buy coffee from
a store like starbucks or something like
that,
it has mold on it and the way that,
like a coffee is stored in the way of
coffee is treated when it comes off of,
right out of the plantations taken care
of to is directly proportionate to how
healthy it is for you and those
mycotoxins.
You haven't moldy coffee or really
fucking bad for you.
That's where liver toxicity and all
these different,
these different effects that he like.
There's an issue with some coffee is not
bad for you at all,
but other coffee shows like bad liver
markings and what that is,
is fungus.
It's in corn and it's in coughing to the
bunch of different shit.
What kind of coffee is it?
A lot of different colleges.
Big Guys.
Will you ever see there's a show called
the dangerous grounds show is about a
dude who.
He's on the travel channel.
He travels to all these different exotic
places where they make coffee like shows
you what it's like to acquire coffee and
these tropical lands on and he was
saying that somewhere between 70 plus
percent of all the coffee you get has
mold on it and that could be a health
issue.
So when people are talking about the
health issues of coffee,
Dave asprey guy says they're talking
about mycotoxins and when you're dealing
with toxin free,
clean fungus,
free coffee,
you don't have nearly as many issues and
the energy does it.
You don't crash afterwards.
What he's saying is that you're
basically being poisoned by shitty
coffee.
Isn't the water killing all that stuff?
No.
That's the crazy thing about fungus.
Not too good.
I know it's getting worse.
It sounds like it's fake.
You should get a stephen hawkings device
was one of those little things and
click,
click.
I don't want to do it.
I don't want to get strep man.
Oh,
he's not contagious at that.
Yeah.
Just don't make out with them.
Um,
your question.
No,
they can't.
It doesn't.
The boiling,
it doesn't kill them.
See,
they can survive in space.
They can survive on radiation.
Yeah.
Spores can survive and insane places.
That's one of the main reasons why some
people believe that a magic mushrooms
came from outer space.
The idea being that there's,
there's,
they're very different and far as the
chemical composition from other
mushrooms and other and they mirror
human neurochemistry and they could
survive in a vacuum that did survive
incredible radiation and we know that
certain shit has come here from
asteroids.
We know water's come here from
We know that things have hit other
planets and sent things to us and could
have contained organic matter.
We know,
we know all that,
so they're pretty sure that these
fucking spores,
these spores can survive in space.
And that's how we got some of these
mushrooms.
Well,
you know that's like prior to that shit
that causes mad cow disease that can
survive like a thousand degrees for like
seven days or something crazy like that.
Like they're,
they're in,
they're insanely tolerant.
Does this stuff keeps you awake at
night?
Know your head is filled with a lot of
fucked up.
Fucked up.
It's fucked up.
You know,
that's a compliment.
But it's just the way I say it.
So can I take a fucking lake?
Yeah.
Go take a leak.
Go through that door and say what
happens if I take a leak?
You guys could come on right back.
We'll,
we'll keep talking.
This is casual as fuck man.
It's the Internet.
You looking at the CEO's of the company
right here.
You just never take a break.
We do whatever we want.
So if I needed to take a break,
if I leave,
will he be talking about me?
No,
unless you want me to help fucking
though.
Whatever you want.
Man wants to be talked about whether or
not in the room.
Are you checking your twitter like a
little girl?
What are you doing here,
man?
Yeah.
It was just checking it out.
Why not get a couple of plugs in?
That would help.
Fuck.
Got a few followers for Christ sake.
Follow OPI radio.
O P I e Dot.
Go through that door and take a right
right here.
Wouldn't talk some shit about you.
Where you're going.
What's that?
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Really?
Yeah.
You got.
Yeah,
there's a story.
I knew a motherfucker.
We got to hear something.
There's a story.
He's got something to show us.
So a poor,
poor Brian.
You got the band aids and uh,
you should call Peter Duesberg up right
now.
And tell him to go fuck himself.
Okay.
Listen,
Peter Duesberg,
I got mouth aids.
Yeah.
STREP is no joke.
Two,
how many days is stripped a contagious
for a,
I think it's the first 48 hours.
Forty eight hours after taking the
medication and how many hours you've
been taking the medication?
Seventy two.
So you buffed it give a little buffer.
It feels like there's a piece of glass
in my throat.
Dude,
you sound like you're sucking cock for
years.
Like they just put you on a cock sucking
plant.
You know,
you just for for a year,
you were in a cock sucker plantation and
that's what they did.
They just lined you up and you got to
just suck hawks all day for years.
Can you imagine a world would that
existed?
Would that was the punishment that
someone would bestow upon you?
GotTa Suck Cox for years,
for years and years and years and years.
You have two years in the cock sucking
factory.
So they sent me someplace and your
life's existence is you get four hours
sleep a night and the rest of the time
while you're awake,
you're sucking decks.
That's your whole day.
You get like five minutes to shove some
food down your throat,
five minutes to shit twice a day.
And then the rest of it is just sucking
or death.
Your choice.
There was a guy who did something to
someone and paralyzed him and the
punishment that they gave him was to
paralyze him
medically.
Yeah.
I forget what the story was.
I going to find,
uh,
the ruling judge's ruling.
This was like a,
I want to say a couple of years ago.
They apparently has a man found guilty
of paralysis.
Okay.
Let's see.
Apparel
paralyzes them.
One of those words we learned.
Oh,
paralysis.
Perfect.
What happened?
I'm talking about some guy who,
uh,
Saudi Arabia was gonna paralyze a man
who crippled another man.
[inaudible] w I wonder how this,
they were going to.
This guy had crippled someone so they
were trying to,
uh,
they wanted a severed his spinal cord
cripple him as punishment.
Right?
And people got really fucking freaked
out about it.
The Guy,
um,
he stabbed someone and severed their
spinal cord and they were going to do
the same thing to him because under
Sharia law,
this guy,
uh,
his victim requested that really?
Yeah,
I just live in that world under Sharia
law.
This was his right to seek to wacky as
part of the world.
They still deal with.
I mean,
as an adult and especially as a father
when you read about the,
the,
the craziness in the world when you see
like some woman who was just gunned down
because she was a,
they thought she possibly has been
guilty of adultery.
So the guy gunder down the street and
everybody's fine with it and you're
allowed to.
How these honor killings is don't stick.
Our country could use a little of that
honor killings.
We'll just something.
What do you mean?
Fuck man,
like the Aurora shooter.
I don't feel like seeing his fucking
face on the news every day.
Why can't we just take them out back and
shoot him in the fucking head?
Okay.
But that's a big difference between that
and honored that.
I was just bringing it all together.
No,
of course I don't want honor killings in
America.
I was like,
what do you think?
I think we're a bunch of pussies as far
as we take care of some of these fucking
people.
You want to take care of school
shootings?
Fucking fucking take these guys out
immediately.
Yeah.
You have to also find out what the fuck
is going on with her mind though in
keeping them alive.
You can study them.
You could find out what,
what we might be able to prevent ones in
the future.
We might have like markers or flags that
they think,
yeah,
they gotta they gotta figure out what it
is psychologically and they also have to
figure out what it is.
I'm chemically right,
because a lot of these guys are on
antidepressants more than 90 percent of.
In fact,
I think.
I think the mental illness part of this
whole equation is way worse than the
fucking gun part.
Yeah,
you're,
you're right.
Absolutely right.
I mean,
Timothy,
Timothy Mcveigh killed a lot of people
with fertilizer.
Right?
If somebody wants to kill you,
they can kill you.
And I agree with you.
Yeah.
This is such a weird chill environment.
Is it?
Yeah,
man.
Just do it.
So out of my element.
No,
you know,
but it's cool though,
but what I'm trying to step out of my
comfort zone does these days different
things.
Yeah.
Because like the type of radio show I
do,
I,
I could almost do it in my sleep now.
Right,
right,
right.
And you got to test environment to me is
really fucking strange.
I'm just,
I'm just pointing out some shit.
You guys have really become a home for
the comedian hangout,
right?
You know,
we used to hate comics on the,
on the,
uh,
show.
Really?
Yeah.
When we're in Boston.
Wow.
We fucking hated it.
And then when we first kicked in New
York,
we fucking hate it because we had guys
that came in and instead of just having
the conversation we're having or just be
funny because if you're a standup,
can't you just be funny and about a lot
of these guys at first because we
weren't getting the quality comics
either because we just starting out,
they came in and they wanted their pit
set up.
Why can't you just come in and have a
conversation and maybe we'll fit in one
of your bits or whatever.
I don't give a fuck,
but let's talk about some shit and maybe
you get some jokes out there.
So we actually avoid a comics for a long
fucking time.
And then,
you know,
when you do radio in New York,
you can't avoid it.
And we finally embraced it and you know,
we'd love it.
Of course we love when you guys come in.
Well,
you guys figured out how to do it the
perfect way,
then let real comics come in and just
fuck around and shoot the shit and talk
shit and it creates these unbelievably
hysterical moment.
Sure.
Whereas,
you know,
if you got a guy just come in and set up
as bits,
how long can you do that for you?
That's not even a real conversation,
but that's what they want.
A lot of radio stations they like even I
did,
I did a big radio station like a couple
of years ago and they still asked me to
do this.
Oh really?
They go,
we would like you to know,
uh,
what questions you would like to be
asked to set up your bids.
And I go set up my bits.
And the guy was like,
disappointed.
They're like,
what bits are you going to do?
I go,
what am I going to do?
What we did not,
we did not know who's coming into your
fucking show.
Yeah.
I can understand if it's somebody where
maybe the comedy club made you take him,
but someone like you.
Really it was,
why would you waste your time with that
shit?
I only did it because I was not.
I don't mean you then when they had an
opportunity to have you just,
you know,
talking on the radio show itself was
great.
It was the producer that was just
weirded me out with all the was so
disappointed in me that I didn't have
bits of prepared and I was like,
what bits are you going to do?
And I was like,
what are you talking about man?
Can we just go out there,
put us,
put us on that radio thing,
right?
Get out of here.
You're fucking my head man.
Exactly.
And those dudes do fuck with your head
too because part of like a fun radio
show is like having a good time and
being relaxed
and when you're around someone who's
super tense,
what they don't understand as they tend
to you up to.
Right?
You're like,
why you so weirded out about me going on
the radio or stop being a pussy.
Just press play.
Well with that said,
how many cool shows are,
are there out there?
Very few.
Right?
It's like a handful,
a handful,
handful scattered across the country
named five.
Kevin had been in la for sure,
and I'll say this,
there might be,
there might be more.
I'm just telling you named five because
you're going to piss off somebody.
No,
I can't.
Then I'll stop right there.
I'm not because I don't mean to know,
but I'm just,
I'm just want to hear any nonsense from
Alex Jones.
Alex Jones,
all you need,
ladies and gentlemen,
we've got Internet radio.
We've got live radio.
We are a hundred people strong in
affiliate.
One of the best things is when Jim
Norton said,
uh,
about Alex Jones and never thought of.
He brought up this brilliant point.
Was that how he always talks about like
the government is,
they're changing the papers.
They're doing this with the papers,
but then he uses the government's
research and papers for other points.
But it's true.
It's like you can't do both,
right?
You can,
but it's not as effective.
That sounds like it hurts a lot to tell
them.
Yeah.
That's like fucked up.
Yeah,
he definitely does do that.
I mean,
look.
Well,
don't worry about all that,
but Alex is also a guy who,
uh,
you know,
he'll,
he'll research shit that a lot of people
wouldn't.
He'll find out some things and a lot of
people wouldn't.
Maybe he's a little wacky.
Yeah,
I would say.
he's a little wacky.
My Pierce Morgan,
it was awesome.
I loved,
it was just great fucking TV.
It's just great theater.
I just went,
loved it when he was pretending when he
was having the English accent,
who's was talking to a peer.
So I think it's actually,
it's like Alex,
you crazy motherfucker.
I wouldn't have blamed peers if you
punched him at that point,
but yeah,
he appears,
I think in the end it's just a fucking
pussy.
Yeah,
he really did say you're just a pussy.
He seems very gross to me.
I Dunno.
Peers.
Yeah.
Some very dirty.
There's some.
Yeah,
there's something going on there and he
got into some shit over there in
England,
so he's dirty.
Yeah.
But it's just like,
I think he's a very intelligent guy and
he's a very good host.
But man,
I feel like if he was involved in
tabloid journalism before,
this is what she was.
Yeah.
It just seems like,
why would you,
why do you want to talk to that guy
right there?
Those kind of guys are gross.
Like that thing,
the tabloid journalism like that.
It's just really.
And they did this sneaky shit.
They like listening on people's phones
and stuff.
That was peers.
Yeah.
That is really gross.
That's really gross stuff.
You know?
It's like,
why?
Why would anybody want to get involved
with that?
But Alex wanted to deport them because
he said something about the second
amendment is going after him.
It's like,
so it was just great theater,
deported.
They know.
You go back to England and socialism,
you can't take our guns.
He gets so angry and just watch you do
that.
Well,
he's so fun to watch and you see pierce
like holding it down in very
professional.
He plays,
he played them like a master.
But when you don't understand is you can
never win against Alex Jones because he
will never feel ridiculous.
Slight pierces trying to like embarrass
him by being quiet while Alex Jones
screams and yells,
but then you just allow Alex Jones to go
into full Alex Jones mode and then
you're fucked because then you're
dwarfed by his personality and he's
saying Hilarious Shit.
You know,
he's talking to you in an English
accent.
You're not even addressed.
Again.
Cheerio old chap.
Can't take all guns away and pierce is
just peers.
We'll have him back because he knows.
That's good.
That's good tv.
I'm sure he will have to.
I'm sure he will have them back.
So what else is going on here that they
went from Larry King to that guy so
fast.
They had to do something.
I guess we've had Larry on the show.
He's awesome.
He's elect Larry.
He.
He tells a good story.
Still the smell.
He looks like he would like antique
bookstore or something.
Yeah,
he's.
He's awesome.
He has lots of great stories.
You can have mine.
He'll do it.
Seemed like a real nice guy.
I've done his show a couple times when
he was on CNN a couple times for fear
factor.
Really.
Was that intimidating?
Being on CNN,
it was weird because that's a big
international audience.
It was very friendly.
He was very friendly.
So no,
that didn't bother me.
No.
You ever get nervous about people
watching me on TV?
None of that show.
I don't really know what you did between
the UFC and fear factor and I've just
done it so many times,
especially the UFC,
which is like,
to me the like I owe those people that
are fighting.
I owe them my best performance more than
anybody.
Doesn't mean like the guy has a great
fight and I don't do great commentary
over his great fight.
To me it doesn't feel like,
you know,
if I fail my,
my side of the bargain,
I,
I feel very shitty.
So have any of those guys ever taken a
swing at you?
For?
Some dudes have been upset at me,
but I've never been disrespectful in my
depictions of like,
I don't like in a weird way,
it's brave because you're living.
That's a crazy world to live in this
crazy world and you're critiquing some
of these guys.
I've always water men.
I wonder if just one of those guys have
taken a shot at it doesn't mean that
they can't kick my ass,
but it doesn't mean that I'm wrong.
I know.
I know what could make them better,
you know,
but they don't want to hear that.
So that's why I wonder if they've ever
taken it personally and by the way,
they might not even be able to
physically achieve what I'm asking them
to do.
Some guys that get into striking too
late and uh,
you know,
you could say,
well he needs to do is really go to a
great striking camp and really get a
striking together because he's missing
this big hole.
There were some guys athletically,
I don't know what it is,
but they know they can never really get
the striking part downright.
It's weird thing.
It's like sometimes you see it in it's
rare wrestlers who have been wrestling
for a long time and um,
for whatever reason they can't seem to
get snap and their punches.
It's really weird.
And there's some guys who have it like
right away,
like you,
you start holding the pads for them and
right away they're scary as fuck with
their power.
They're just super athletes.
But some guys can't get that striking
together.
And I don't know what that is.
I really don't understand it.
I've seen it.
I don't know if it's an age thing.
I don't know if they caught it too late
in life and they don't.
They just cannot develop the kind of
explosive that shit is obviously
movement.
Yeah.
And when you see these guys okay.
Immediately.
To me they look,
they all look like they could strike.
Well yeah.
Well it's one of those things where if
you,
the more you appreciate martial arts,
the more you understand martial arts,
the in the more techniques that you
know,
the more you appreciate seeing the
application of the techniques.
So like when people say like,
you know why you getting so excited
about it,
you know,
mma,
why do you watch a Jujitsu matches and
go crazy.
Like why you get so excited about it?
Because I know how hard it is to do with
that guy's doing.
I know it intimately,
you know,
so when you see a guy who's triangle and
some guy and you hear me screaming,
it's because this fucking dude just
pulled off a crazy as triangle.
It's hard to do.
Right?
So I am extra excited because I'm
intimately aware of how difficult it is
to do with this guy's trying to do.
Oh,
I love how you call fights.
It's great.
It's fun,
man.
It's,
it's a fun Gig,
right?
That,
that's,
that's the only thing that I ever.
I don't,
I wouldn't say nervous.
That's the only thing that I ever do.
I feel like my responsibility is more
than just me.
It's like the,
the,
the guys fighting as well.
It's a sport to the fact that,
you know,
the fan base of millions of fans,
if I'm their favorite guy to do this,
like I can't like slack off.
They're like that,
that I take like I take that super
seriously.
So if I ever do feel pressure it's then.
But that pressure is good pressure,
you know?
But like as far as like doing this or
doing Larry King or something like that,
it was easy.
Like I did TV yesterday.
I'm doing a show for TVS.
Who gets the last laugh?
It's a passionate coachers company.
Oh really?
They're kind of reinventing punked.
I did something with Ashton Kutcher's
company.
They were great people.
I didn't meet,
I didn't meet astrium but the people
were awesome.
I'm handsome men,
so I'm in front of the line for
features.
I'm in front of a live audience,
you know,
on a,
on a stage,
sort of.
They're basically like,
I directed a prank,
kind of like what you've seen on,
you know,
on pumped and there's three of us and we
all,
uh,
directed a prank and then we present it
to a live studio audience.
That's fucking horrifying for me.
But I,
but I could do radio,
like,
you know,
I never get nervous doing radio.
But you're also doing radio to your fans
while.
Yeah,
I mean,
first of all,
they,
they introduced me.
No one knows who the fuck I am.
Well you didn't stack the deck.
What do you mean you didn't tell the ONA
fans to get tickets?
I should've.
I know.
Know keeps you.
Shall throw that fucking phone in the
toilet.
You do that little bird that keeps going
off for a couple minutes to burn.
In a previous podcast we talked about
previous podcast.
We were talking about how every time I'm
at a restaurant that goes out,
people are like,
you just whistle at me with a little
weird.
I gotta be honest with you.
Look,
it's one of my guys.
Great interview and Rogan asked to try
his uh,
uh,
deprivation tank.
Trippy.
I do want to try that.
I want to float to do a.
is there a place in New York where you
could do it?
I don't know.
I gotta look it up.
But anyway.
Yeah,
I need to open one.
But it was horrified just presenting my
stupid prank.
So if you stack the deck with a ONA
fans,
I don't think you would have been.
They were cool.
There was no.
Yeah,
it was great.
It was great because it was funny.
But my point is I don't do a lot of tv,
so when I do,
it's like you want to talk about
stepping out of your comfort zone.
Fuck yeah,
that could fuck with you.
That's like what?
Like when you see those sportscaster
guys that had been doing it like a
million years and they were like,
you know,
like the nfl guys or any of these guys
that had been,
you know,
they just so smooth and whatever they
do,
they've been there,
done that.
So it's all about doing the job.
It's not about,
oh shit,
we're on TV.
That's out the window now.
It's just about being a job.
Yeah.
He used to be nervous doing radio.
I mean,
but that left years ago.
So the only person who's ever
intimidated me,
it was a ray Liotta,
diddy,
intimidating,
you know what it was about him.
But he came in recently and I,
I definitely did better.
I just did better.
He was one of these guys,
man,
I don't know what it is.
I was fucking intimidating the first
time he came in where I was barely
talking and he finally looked at me and
he goes,
hey,
is that guy sick,
sick,
sick.
I don't know what it was.
It's like,
no one else does that to me.
But Ray Liotta and then the fans knew
and then when know when he was coming
back in,
they were all talking about tweeting and
you know,
I did all right the second time.
But he's a bad motherfucker.
I don't know what it is.
I guess respect for his acting funky.
Goodfellas.
Fuck you.
Come on man.
Did you ever see him in New York?
He's in Narcan,
right?
No.
To breathing.
Yoda is a bad motherfucker was a bad
ass.
So I think it's him in the dark.
You're gonna have to look that shit up.
Okay.
I have to go to the imd and see what's
up.
But uh,
just his performance and goodfellows.
I mean,
to me it was so good the way he was
keeping everything together,
you know,
running back and forth between the coke
house,
his girlfriend there and she throws a
brick of coke.
Adam.
It was just like when,
when he was in the car and he was
driving around the helicopters were over
the head like you were there with him
and kid and your high with them and I
don't know what the fuck.
Yeah,
really owed.
It was in that.
I don't know what the fuck they did to
his eyes and that scene.
I mean maybe they kept him up and gave
him coke because he looked like he was
coked out.
No,
those are the eyes that that's what did
it.
Yeah.
I was staring at his,
at his eyes,
you know,
because when you're,
you got guys in your interview and you
got to look them right in the fucking
eyes.
And I was looking in his eyes.
I'm like,
fuck,
that's fucking freaking me the fuck out.
Freaking me out.
That scene where his eyes were all
fucked up and he was driving in the car.
I'm like,
that guy.
That's pretty much his eyes so well,
but I'm telling you that it's pretty
much his eyes in general.
So you ever think about like a shit
actor doing that same part.
If you take some guy with an actor,
of course can do that same part that him
knowing where it really oded ever done
it and this is difference and would we
know,
we would not know.
Goodfellas is a good movie.
Yeah.
I wonder about that a lot.
Like these bad fucking comedies that
come out.
You wonder if they got a different guy.
Would that have changed everything?
Yeah.
If you got.
You don't mean if you've got someone
else to play this character.
This movie could never been as good.
Ray Liotta was born to play this cat.
Sure,
but it's not saying that someone
couldn't have come up with something
else.
Do you like caring about the actors that
were also up for roles like that?
That's always fascinating.
Yeah.
I don't have an example right now.
Nobody could have done this.
He was so fucking perfect with this.
It was so perfect.
What are you looking at it?
Looking at?
Look at sheer.
There is that guys.
There's a few of those guys out there
that are like real craftsman.
Like Daniel Day Lewis,
really?
Yoda,
Russell Crowe.
Before he got fat and lazy.
We could still kick it out of the park,
man.
He wanted to.
He's been gone a while now.
Yeah.
He needs a hit.
But it's,
you know what it is.
They keep the just get fucking crazy.
It's nutty life to be a movie star out
there.
Jet Set in the globe trying to keep your
shit together.
Or would you like to do that?
Fuck that.
No.
Why not?
Zero interest in making movies was
because it's not fun.
It's,
it's thing you build up to a long point
in time and then the fun things in the
movie comes out.
Yay.
And then nobody likes it.
But all that making of the movie shit.
That shit takes forever.
It takes forever.
You're stuck in a time of.
Yeah.
No,
nothing.
Not really interested.
I get it.
I see how other people would like to do
it.
But to me I said it can be podcasting,
you know,
or I could be doing standup or I could
be doing something else.
Like why would I want to do that?
I want to do that.
She looks boring.
My,
uh,
my latest thing is exploring the
exploring New York City.
Oh,
really?
Exploring.
Did you ever see dark days where the
bowl people used to live?
Oh,
dark days is a grit.
Well,
I shouldn't say it's a great document.
It's a weird document.
It's a weird.
It's a really cool documentary.
It's black and white and basically it
talks about the Amtrak tunnel under,
uh,
the upper west side.
Uh,
and you went down in there.
Yeah,
I've been wanting to do that forever
because you worry about the super aids
that are not super a pitcher.
If you go that far to the middle of the
earth,
the fuck would happen.
When did you do this post or Pre Sandy?
Uh,
after I only about a month ago.
There's a guy coming on our show that,
uh,
I forgot the name of his book.
Hidden cities of the world are under a
fuck.
You could probably look it up.
His name's Moses because you have a TV
show.
No,
but he's connected with a lot of those
guys there.
It's like a,
it's like a network of guys and they go
around the world like,
Hey,
you come to Paris,
I'll show you our shit and then we'll
come to New York.
You show us your shit.
So you went with them.
I went with this Guy Moses and we went
into the,
the old Amtrak tunnel and the train
still run,
but that's where the mole people used to
live under riverside park on the upper
west side and we went into a little
fucking rat hole on the side of the
highway and there was one holy wanted me
to go through them.
Like get the fuck out of here was just
garbage and smell,
like just horrendous.
I go,
let's see if there's another hole.
And we went a little further and sure
enough there was a whole just enough to
get your fucking body in and then all of
a sudden you're,
you're under underground in this tunnel.
Where were these people lived?
Wow.
Some of these people lived down there
for like 20,
25 years.
They kicked everybody out.
They kicked them out in,
um,
I don't know,
like the mid nineties finally.
How weird are people that they just find
these little collective groups of other
people willing to live in a tunnel and
they find each other and they all live
together.
Yeah.
I mean,
a lot of them are drug addicts.
How many down there?
They don't really know.
I mean,
some say hundreds.
Some say thousands.
They don't really know.
In dark days.
They,
the documentary,
they didn't do a really good job because
I would have loved to know that type of
shit.
They focused on,
uh,
probably uh,
about a dozen people that were living
down there.
How would they built a little really
nice fucking living arrangements for
themselves down there.
Like,
really?
Yeah man,
like little shanty towns.
But they had cable,
they have electricity.
They caught the TV,
that TV they plugged into.
They figured out how to plug into
everything.
It was all free.
They had pipes that they broke for their
showers that was just constantly running
cold water.
They would take really ice cold showers.
Really?
Yeah.
They had pets down there.
When I went down there recently,
it was me,
this Guy Moses,
and we saw three people the entire time
we walked under ground two and a half
miles to the way out.
I mean when you commit you got to go the
distance and it's two and a half miles
to get the fuck out or he got to where
are you going to come back from where
you came from?
Duke.
And we only saw three other people and
they were explorers to.
So they were explorers as well.
Yeah,
checking,
checking that shit out.
So there's a lot of people that go on
and explore it.
I mean not a lot.
I mean that day there was what,
five of us total.
So there's.
Yeah,
that's not big for New York.
Right.
And it's a creepy thing to do though,
isn't it kind of creepy man.
It was cool though.
But the relative to being in the woods,
that stuff that used to be there,
what they do with it all,
they just pulled it all out of there and
yeah,
they cleaned it up yet because Amtrak
had it and they.
I guess I,
I,
I think that the tunnels weren't being
used back then or they weren't being
used a lot in Amtrak,
one of their fucking tunnel back.
So they kicked all the people out and
they cleared,
cleaned house,
got all the Shit outta there,
but there's beautiful artwork down their
murals from these fucking,
just literally underground artists,
graffiti artists and shit off from the
people that lived in there.
Pretty fucking cool stuff because the
greats,
you know,
where people walk above obviously,
uh,
the light comes through right on the
wall and every,
every area that has the light coming
down,
someone drew something or painting
something on the walls.
Wow.
And some of the shit is really fucking
pretty,
pretty good.
That's such a trip.
It's such a trip that they had developed
like a little underground city down
there.
Fuck yeah.
And a lot of these guys would come up
during the day to,
to hustle,
you know,
collect cans and,
make money,
whatever they,
however they could.
Or they go through the garbage and get
their fucking food and then they go back
down.
How long did this go on for?
According to dark days,
they were talking about guys that were
down there for like two decades.
Jesus Christ said fuck it to,
you know,
society to society and decide they want
to live down there,
but a lot of them were drug addicts and
crack heads and shit list.
So many crazy.
But it will in the world,
in the movie a dark days.
Some of the guys would write no crack on
their little homes because they were
sick of people,
you know,
breaking in or knocking,
asking for crack.
So yeah,
it's hard to get crack in the basement.
It's the whole thing.
So there you go.
I keep forgetting that we could check
some of this shit out.
Yeah,
it's so strange.
I recommended.
I mean,
I,
I think the,
I think they could've done a better job
with this documentary,
but it was,
it was definitely cool.
Look,
that guy has a dartboard.
Yeah.
He's got a frigerator behind him.
As a refrigerator.
It's all,
you know,
free electricity and that's crazy.
And so they just tapped into all the
wires and everything.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's really ingenious when it was so
fascinating how people just find a way
to adapt.
Right.
You know,
they find a way to adapt to living in
Siberia.
They find a way to adapt living in the
fucking tunnels.
Right.
They seemed very,
uh,
very happy down there to that it becomes
their life.
Yeah.
And I bet they probably feel like
they're getting away with not paying
rent.
And of course it cripples everybody.
Right.
You're paying rent.
I was creeped out.
I thought I'd see rats down there.
I didn't see any.
And the guy,
Moses I was with,
he's like,
look,
there's no people down here anymore.
And you know,
rats need people to survive.
So they go to the people that are it
because rats basically just eat our
garbage.
I uh,
was on the upper west side once and I
was at a gas station somewhere on the
west side and uh,
I uh,
was on the payphone and it's how long
ago this was and was on the phone and my
car was parked and was getting gas rats
or jumping out of this sewer,
climbing up my wheel and into the
wheelhouse.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Just immediately,
like,
right away looking for like whatever
fucking a sandwich.
I might've run over and saw the tires.
You're looking for a way into the car
looking for a way like into the engine
compartment.
They sense the heat coming off of it.
I mean,
I saw six,
seven rats climb all over my wheels.
It was discussed and they're highly
intelligent.
There's so many.
There's a book out there called rats.
You want to be creeped out to.
Highly intelligent.
Yeah.
They really are.
And they learn and you know,
it's really tough to fucking trap them
and all that shit.
Really.
They understand when you're fucking up
their environment.
Oh yeah.
That they,
you know,
they,
they set up all their paths and stuff.
So you know,
dopey humans go,
oh well I'll put the fucking rat trap
right where their path is.
They.
They understand that shit.
They're fully aware.
Yeah.
Rat traps.
Not enough of those cons.
No.
We've got to come up with robots at eat
rats.
They say there's more rats in New York
City than people and they s in this
book,
they said at any given time,
this is,
this will blow your mind at any given
time when you're walking around New York
City,
there's a rat within feet of you.
Wow.
Because they have all this,
you know,
these tunnels under the sidewalk and all
that shit.
So they dig their own tunnels under the
sidewalk.
Love fucking tunnels.
But according to this book,
at any given moment in New York City or
very close to a rat,
wouldn't that be nice if they had an APP
for that?
So you'd go and you look at your phone
like how many rats are near me?
And you look in everywhere and your
feet.
It's like that scene in aliens when the
little girl is hiding and the aliens are
coming through the ceiling.
You look all over the ground,
it's like rats are underneath you and
tunnels everywhere.
I think people would move out.
They wouldn't be so fucking comfy and
cozy in their upper east side,
you know,
penthouses.
If you could look down,
you know,
with a,
with a phone and just see all the rats
moving.
I need to serve as you know,
uh,
the Plaza Hotel obviously in New York.
Yeah,
I think it was the daily news did an
article about the park across the street
is infested with rats.
And the reason is because the horse,
the horse and carriages,
you know,
they put all the feed down so that shit
is everywhere.
So it's a great food source for rats.
So I read about it in the,
um,
the paper.
I went there that night and they said
you got to wait til the sun goes down.
And sure the fuck there were rats
everywhere.
Hopping across the fucking lawns and
everything.
Did you freak out?
Sometimes they run like two feet.
What?
Fuck you.
I don't know if it's because they're
excited.
I have no fucking idea.
Not Not a lot,
but enough to creep you out.
Like what the fuck?
Rats running.
Oh yeah.
And then there are people or people were
just kind of sitting on benches and shit
and rats were literally right behind
them and they didn't know my because I
was fully aware because the article
somebody and they climb on people
sometimes to just sit in there.
Any of that,
but.
But then you also see all the paths
where the,
where they're coming from.
Yeah.
Fuck paths from one bus to another.
How many didn't think you saw that
night?
A couple of dozen probably.
Oh yeah.
They came out man.
And that's probably a tiny fraction of
how many of them are tiny little park.
It's like,
I dunno.
Yeah,
it's like maybe four times the space
we're in right now.
Let's see.
Just a small part,
but it was infested.
Sure.
The city hasn't cleaned it up since.
So how do they do something like that?
If you want.
If you want to check out rats,
go there.
It's across the street from the plaza,
not central park.
Which is right there too.
How do they keep a rat population?
Correct.
Does guys that make a shitload of money?
Just killing rats.
Killing rats.
I totally do.
Yeah.
These,
these buildings,
they.
They hire the best guys and they make a
fortune keeping these buildings red
free.
You need cats.
Cats are the way to go.
We,
we cooked up rats on our radio show and
you ate it.
You didn't know about that one?
No.
Maybe we did more shit at new than
satellite.
Really?
Yeah.
One day we got the idea.
I don't remember why.
Maybe there's some dump cooking show on
baby bird.
The bird was the greatest fucking bit
ever.
Oh,
and we got to talk about the destroyer
before I get out of here.
The nickname you gave me,
right?
You were there for probably the greatest
bit we ever did.
Baby Bird.
But let me tell you about the rat thing
real fast.
So at new we decided to cook up rats and
we actually got listeners to come in to
eat rat.
Wow.
And I looked at Anthony.
I'm like,
there's no way,
but we'll try.
So we,
we,
you know,
we threw the question out there who
would come in and eat rats,
phones fucking lit up and people like
Ali Rats.
So we had two cooks come in.
God,
we had one guy that was a French chef
and we had just a fucking run of the
mill barbecue type guy and they,
they both had live rats.
We gave them the live rats and they had
to do everything else.
And one guy killed the rat,
like very humane.
He found a spot on the neck or whatever
and just fucking stabbed the real fast.
The thing was dead in a second,
half a second and the other guy fucking
took his bread was just bludgeoning to
death on the side of the table.
Oh my God killed him because he didn't
know how else this is on the radio,
on regular radio.
Oh my God.
And then the French chef,
uh,
you know,
had a nice recipe and he made like a,
I remember this brown sauce and a nice
feel like I was there,
nice presentation and the other guy just
fucking cooked up this bloody mess.
Didn't even just cook the whole thing
basically,
but when you know,
the listers came in and they tried the,
the,
especially the one by the French chef,
they went back for seconds.
It went back for seconds.
Well,
not only did they say the store ran or
was it a street?
Um,
I don't,
I don't remember where we got the
restaurant and being completely honest
with you.
I was,
we were trying to get like subway rats,
but I think we might end up getting them
from a pet store.
So.
But they were big ugly motherfucker
things on youtube by the way.
It's under opion is probably full show
rat eating,
so.
Oh yeah,
check that out.
Wow.
But then you were there the first time
we did radio together though,
I think was in Vegas at the poker
tournament.
No,
it wasn't in Vegas.
It was out here.
It was in California.
Oh,
and yeah,
in California.
Was that the first time you're on?
Was Ed asner called you the destroyer?
Well,
yeah.
But then he was at Asbury.
But then you push that forward.
Well,
you,
you came the first time we did the,
did radio together.
Uh,
yes.
Yeah,
that is.
I didn't,
I didn't really.
I knew of you and your standup obviously
and like I said earlier,
you know,
you support us and we finally got to do
radio together and Anthony was in the
poker tournament.
Yes.
So I'm like,
Yo Joe,
you know,
hang out,
let's do this.
Yeah,
we had a good time and asked her.
Came on.
I mean he had no reason to be on our
show to be honest with you.
He's a great guy.
He just,
he was all right.
He's you and.
And you started fucking with a full.
No we didn't,
we didn't,
we got along.
But uh,
I,
I had recently explained this a
somewhere that um,
I do that shit just to get a fucking.
Get a rise out of someone out of you.
Not.
Yeah.
I don't give a fuck about.
So you,
you went after him to get a rise out of
them.
That's how fucked up.
That's fucked up and showmanship.
I did it to superfly Jimmy snuck in the
other day.
Oh,
did you really?
Well,
back in 83,
a woman died that he was with and it was
very suspicious,
very suspicious.
He says she fell on some rocks.
They were driving to a wrestling match
or something and stopped at a rest area
and she was checking out a stream and
she fucking hit her head and then by the
time we got into the hospital and stuff,
she was dead.
But some say,
yeah,
you might have had something to do with
it.
Maybe he didn't know.
He imagine if that was actually just as
girlfriend and you're accusing him of
killing her and you know,
we got a video,
horrible and it's one of my latest
videos on my youtube channel because
what happened was I,
we,
we asked him the story which,
which was pretty big because I wasn't
sure he was going to talk about it and
he told the whole fucking story and just
to get a rise out.
Everyone in the room.
I go,
well,
what is she doing now?
Knowing what,
and look at the reaction I'm getting
now,
but that's just to get everyone in the
room.
Extremely approachable.
And that's what happened with asthma.
It hasn't,
it didn't do anything to me,
but for the people that don't know,
a producers started giving me hand
signals and stuff like he was trying to
get my attention for something else.
It might even been where I was at in the
poker tournament.
And uh,
who,
who said,
what does that mean?
Was it you were at asthma owner about
what would that hand signals that lead
to what I did?
I don't remember.
Oh,
okay.
But anyway,
like someone asks like,
what?
Why is that guy giving,
you know,
hand signals.
And I said,
well,
when the guest is boring,
I said this right as there I go with the
guest is boring,
they'd give me you hand signals to get
them off the fucking air.
And that's what they're called the
destroyer.
And for some reason that made you really
happy.
It was hilarious.
Made you really happy.
It was fun because you were,
you were fucking with them obviously,
but it was good nature.
It wasn't that.
But you also got into a fight with a
poker player that when we were there,
you were there for me.
You mean you're talking about d dot
Grano?
Yeah.
I didn't.
I didn't really get into an argument.
He just wrote some stuff on his blog.
We weren't feeling them that day.
We weren't feeling.
Um,
he,
he's a good guy.
Just he misunderstood what I was saying.
He thought that I was talking shit about
his ex girlfriend.
I was not doing that.
I was talking about like what?
And he realized that he went back and
looked at the listen to it and actually
wrote an apology on his website.
Oh really?
He's a nice guy,
you know,
I got no problem with.
We didn't,
I don't know.
I was doing radio.
We were talking about.
It was on Xm,
so we were talking,
we were having some fun.
We're having fun.
And then you were the one that
officially came up with baby bird say is
probably right up there.
One of our greatest
beds,
our,
I think bill bird named it.
It was,
it might've been building.
Said the name baby bird.
Was it your ideas?
My idea.
I can't take credit for that one.
My idea was,
uh,
we were doing the eggnog contest,
which we no longer can do.
It's illegal now.
Fuck.
Stupid lady died that drinking water?
Yeah.
We usually shut down spring pat from Iu
knocky.
They shut down to see what he.
Were you there the year the guy ate the
fruit loops with the puke milk?
Yes.
I saw Pat Duffy.
What did he do with that day?
I think pat.
Yeah.
Well I was there when he did it.
He had pat dot because we brush his
teeth with dog shit with cat shit.
Shit,
dog shit.
He's fucking crazy.
He's,
he's on.
He's on twitter.
Just love Pat Duffy.
I love him too.
But whatever happened to him,
how come he's not working for you guys?
Because we can't do the stunts anymore.
But we got,
we got a couple of positions that are
open.
So you know,
he wants to interview for depressed the
other day.
It sounded so sad.
So really.
And he called in the Jim Martin show and
he's just like,
nothing's working for me.
I'm on my last.
It's him.
He's willing to eat shit.
He did amazing stuff for us,
but he was the one that decided to go
over the garbage pail when pat from
Inaki Start puking from toe.
We knew pat from when Daca was gonna
Puke.
So what we're trying to figure out what
would be the most fucked up way to cap
off this already awesome radio show.
Which by the way,
we're on regular radio.
Okay.
This was on regular radio,
so we couldn't swear or anything like
that and me from having doing fear
factor.
It's the only way I would have ever
thought to do this.
I was like,
how about someone leans over the garbage
pail and he throws up in their mouth.
I never thought anyone would say yes.
Duffy's fucking stepped right up.
And Pat Duffy stepped up immediately and
I'm like,
there's no way.
This is really gonna happen.
There's no way it's really going to
happen.
And the cartoonishness of the throw up
coming out of path will knock you.
The fact that it literally all Eggnog,
yeah,
it was 70 something shots of Eggnog and
it was like a broken fire hydrants
dream.
It was the craziest thing I've ever seen
in my life,
the most amazing thing I've ever seen
because you couldn't imagine there was
that much fluid and one guy.
It's just kept going and go in and go,
and if you haven't seen it,
ladies and gentlemen,
you deserve to allow you to tow it.
Youtube took a lot of the,
uh,
videos down with that one.
Well,
this is from a cell phone.
They let the cell phone version.
This is all weekend long,
is unbelievable.
Pat Pat Duffy just sitting there with
his arms crossed,
relaxed and pat from Menarche,
who is about what?
300 plus pounds,
gigantic,
tiny little thin legs and he's got this
huge gut filled with eggnog and he's
ready to blow it all over Pat's face.
And once it goes by the way,
the floor is covered with plastic set up
like a texture cut room.
They couldn't wait to get us out of
there.
They fucking hated it all I'm sure.
Could you imagine?
I didn't want to deal with these fucking
jazz show
that's on and used that studio,
so I haven't seen this in a while.
Perhaps Munafiki.
He said this is it.
He's going,
he's 75 position the cameras and
everything.
He's such a professional fine.
People that call him from all over
America.
They've been puking all over the place.
Every city in America.
Yeah,
because other people had already started
hurling.
They gave up early.
It was you and Bill Burns studio that
day.
Oh,
there it is.
That's happening.
Is happening.
Oh my God.
That's massive.
How big was that and you think there's
no way.
I have seen this video 100 times.
It never gets dumpsters full.
Seven,
seven and he's not done
gallon each.
How do you explain that?
You can't explain,
but how do you explain how much liquid
is coming out of his mouth?
There was a massive,
but how do you explain that?
Like they're massive blast of Linkedin,
so why like rivers coming out of his
mouth?
You remember the Stephen King movie
stand by me with a dude that has the pie
eating contest.
Bitch.
Literally crazier than that.
Oh yeah.
Literally it doesn't believe.
I don't believe that it came out of it.
Body Pat toffee.
I didn't want.
I did one study where we decided to make
ice cream out of his sister's breast
milk,
so and I.
every once in a while I'll step up and
still do some of these fucking bits and
that was one.
For whatever reason I said,
yeah,
I'll fucking do it.
Fuck it.
And the ice cream,
it tasted really good.
He was a first second and then it was
the most horrendous tastes you could
ever imagine.
This.
The Pie eating contest where remember
that?
Oh yeah.
I mean,
here we are,
right?
Stephen King is such a bad motherfucker.
How many good movies and books is this
guy right here?
Yeah.
Trashed us was covered by Pam was what
was more impressive because that looks
more fake.
It did look fake.
You tell them.
You
guys.
Yeah.
I don't remember exactly.
Somebody people.
For what?
Somebody put so many people trashed us.
You forget.
After a while,
Steven went to them.
I think we went after one of his radio
stations or one of his morning show,
the October sort of a thing.
I think someone did.
Someone maybe can help us out.
Is He recently that did this?
A couple of years back.
Okay.
Because recently you guys went after one
in Maine.
It was like a Portland,
Maine when I was laughing my ass off.
It was really funny.
Yeah.
The jock tobar ones are really.
I loved those and I love how they always
shut their facebook pages down,
like almost immediately the past finding
out about it.
Just take that shit.
But he can take,
but they take it to the uh,
the,
the nth degree.
It's Larry.
It's hilarious.
Yeah.
The past,
uh,
like the,
the most loyal and active radio fans I
think of any show.
And they also turn on us as well.
I keep us on our toes.
Like,
fuck.
Yeah,
they uh,
they definitely do at the comedy shows.
I know you guys had some.
We,
I went to one of your shows.
I did one of your shows in Vegas and it
was great.
It was great.
I know our audience has a,
it has to be said.
They are a great comedy crowd.
They will sit down and fucking listen,
man.
Show in Philly the infamous show or that
one they did was a hostile.
Yeah,
well they,
they were drinking all day.
We did these comedy shows across America
and the Philly one is legendary now and
I feel bad because I know you're close
with dom rare,
but he ate his balls that day,
but I've thought about it many times to
sap went on.
He never had a chance.
He never had a chance to.
Jimmy Schubert never had a chance.
And Jimmy Schubert actually bombed in
front of his fucking family that were
basically sitting in the front row.
They had to deal with that shit.
Did Jimmy go on first?
Uh,
know Jimmy came close.
I think,
you know,
I think he went,
who didn't bomb?
Um,
Norton Bill Burr was next.
Bill burr saw what was happening with
Jimmy Schubert and then and then went on
and shit.
And he goes,
you know what,
they're fucking not doing this to me.
And at that point,
our audience didn't really know bill
burr yet,
you know,
they didn't embrace him yet.
Like other guys that came before bill,
he was sort of on the cusp of being
accepted by our big fucking lunatic,
a audience.
And he said,
I ain't doing that shit to me.
So legendary that,
that,
that clip is out there to.
We took on the intox fuck the liberty
bell.
Yeah.
He went after Philadelphia in a way that
nobody's ever done before.
And,
and he,
uh,
he,
they started booing them.
By the end of it,
he got a standing ovation.
It was one of the most amazing things
I've ever seen.
I know what I'm saying that a lot,
but we're bringing up a lot of
benchmarks today.
But that was one of the most amazing
things I've ever seen.
A guy turn a fucking room like that.
Yeah.
That was legit.
And that bothers me about this video.
This,
I wish we had a better copy of this.
Yeah.
It's just shitty cell phone video.
It's somebody a uploaded on.
No,
no.
Got It on their cell phone.
Bill Berg started out in Boston and you
deal with so many crowds like that
drunk,
angry,
crazy fucks that you develop that style
that,
you know,
that attack style that was a Boston
is Boston set tough for you guys?
Boston's a great place,
but every place to do stand up.
Well as long as you got your shit
together,
but I mean when you're coming up,
I would imagine it was hard.
Well,
when,
when bill and I came up,
I was a couple of years before him,
but um,
when we came up there was so many good
comics around that,
like the rules of the land had been
pretty much established and there was a
lot of really good places to do standing
up.
Right.
But there was also like a lot of like
really fucked up little shit holes that
you get sent to Brazil.
It's so important though.
Of course,
you know,
you can't have like only easy crowds
when you're starting out and really
learn how to do comedy.
You got to be able to do some hostile
places.
Right?
So I see like a guy like bill in that
video,
it's like,
that's right up bills out.
You get it,
you do stand up in Boston,
you're going to have to deal with it.
You get it.
I missed those shows.
Were thinking about bringing them back.
We'll send it back,
man.
It'd be fun.
Maybe this coming summer we'll do one or
two.
You were the guy that need you first
came up with the name desk squad.
Do you understand that?
That really,
yeah.
Our show or know the name desk was you
came up with me personally or you did.
You did.
And he called his dad.
He didn't make the name up but he called
us.
That's fine.
You don't want to get a little credit
here.
Joe is going to be able to have credit.
Man.
When I showed up I showed up with tate.
Fletcher was his big giant ultimate
fighter dude.
And uh,
Eddie Bravo.
Sure.
And you go,
here comes Joe Rogan with the desk.
Okay.
I do remember that.
And when you did that,
that literally became the nickname.
We started using it.
So like all the podcasts that are called
the desk,
it all came out of that one thing.
How do I get a little taste?
What do you want?
What do you want a hug?
I got my money,
I got my taste was out.
The tastes of that.
That's,
it's tough to get that New York,
New York,
he gets got some wacky laws.
You know,
MMA is illegal in New York.
No,
I know.
We can't even do a fuck when we talk
about that with Dana white all the time.
It's ridiculous what to do with fucking
culinary union that they bind people
off.
It's amazing.
It's amazing how it works.
But if you're talking about the amount
of revenue that's being lost in the
city,
so why can they work around that knowing
how much money they're losing because
uh,
the,
the industry is set up where the
influence of these unions,
uh,
is,
is really been established.
And when they want to keep something
out,
they spend the money.
They spent a lot of money on anti UFC
propaganda,
anti UFC websites.
They put out,
they put out press releases and can't
make money off of say I don't,
I don't understand.
Here's the airstrip,
break it down to the culinary union is
in dispute with the owners of station
casinos.
Station casinos are a non union
organization and apparently according to
station casinos,
the workers in the casinos voted to not
go union.
They don't want to be involved in human
because they don't want to have to pay
the dues and they believed that the
company treats them fairly and pays them
well.
So since they don't want to be in the
coroner union,
apparently
this is allegedly.
And you know,
I don't really have any direct
connection to any of this knowledge.
This is a lot of hearsay.
Hearsay.
Allegedly.
The Culinary Union would benefit in
terms of millions and millions of
dollars in dues if they got the station
casinos because I think there's like 20
station casinos or something crazy like
that.
If they got those casinos unionized than
it would be very financially beneficial
for them.
So they have a use lobbyists and they've
used to politicians that they have
relationships with and people that they
can pay off to try to keep them in May,
out of New York.
Man,
it's amazing.
It's amazing because his millions of
people in New York and it's a tiny
handful of slots that are keeping them
in Mayo and it's all financial and it's,
it's made from New York City.
Can you imagine?
I don't want to talk out of school,
so I don't know what the real details of
their dispute or I don't want to pretend
that,
you know,
just because I worked for the UFC that
they're correct or anybody's career.
Sure.
But it looks to me like some typical
union goons,
strong arm bullshit,
you know,
and that's a,
I'm a,
I'm,
I think unions are important.
I'm a fan of unions.
I'm a,
I'm a fan of people getting paid well
for,
you know,
for their efforts.
And I think that there's a lot of merit
in that,
but when they do stupid shit like this,
I think it ruins it for all the good
benefits of the Union code.
They started using themselves as a.
they're like a mob of course,
and they're trying to enforce their own
interests and it has nothing to do with
safety or nothing to do with the public.
And to see these for horror politicians
that have been bought off by these
people,
to see them lobbying to keep the UFC
out.
It's just discussed as standard.
Getting closer.
I think so.
I think it's A.
There's Joe Rogan Madison Square Garden,
Madison Square Garden calling a UFC
fucking fight.
Can you imagine?
Yeah,
I could imagine it.
That'll fuck it.
Freaked out a little bit.
No.
Madison Square Garden now I wouldn't
know.
I found from the casino that when you
guys were all there,
it wouldn't.
It wouldn't shake me because it's a
historic building,
but it's at the end of the day,
it's just a building that's true.
You know,
at this,
I mean maybe five years ago would have
freaked me out,
or 10 years.
Is that as.
Look how young you are,
Brian.
He's a little sweetie.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Where is it?
Where are these pictures from?
A.
This is from that casino.
What side of the,
uh,
this is one of my private sites.
Well fuck man.
And I can send them to you.
So my pictures way back in the day.
Wow.
What year was that?
Like 2006.
Was it even.
When were you guys,
when did you guys first get on his,
this guy?
Two thousand four.
I don't know.
I know who that is.
He wants to take a guess.
Some famous.
Very famous.
Was that Michael Clarke?
Duncan.
You were looking at a very famous
athlete.
She said it's Michael Clarke Duncan.
Well,
I can't see it that good.
He's making a crazy face.
We're looking at a very famous.
It was his name.
T Dot Deacon Jones.
Oh,
Deacon Jones.
Who was on?
I think this is 2000 format to them for.
I think we just got on.
When did you start working with me?
I'm 11 years ago,
10 years ago,
so 2002 while we went to sell it.
Yeah,
it was 2004,
2004.
It was like right after you guys went to
satellite.
Yeah.
We're just starting to get back and
shit.
Fuck.
Here's the table.
Funny.
Yeah,
look at that.
Vos Vos was their boss was there,
so it was me,
you,
Vasa,
Jimmy,
and it was playing poker that day and
then Ed Asner,
Steve and I did that just for you
fucking guys because he didn't deserve
it that day.
Boy.
I listened to Vossa and body and
Bonnie's a podcast the other night
driving home.
It was on your station.
Wanted to fucking throw myself out of
the vehicle.
I'm really did hit the gas and kick that
door.
Open leap.
I don't know if you know what I'm
saying.
Is there conflict?
Their concept back and forth conflict.
It's really fun.
I love it.
I really love listening to those two.
The main sheet tortures him and she does
and you know what?
She's smarter than him and that's a bit.
That's a little bit.
Now Richard's going fucking text me.
She's smarter than him and they're in a
trap.
You know,
she's,
she's got them locked up.
Whenever they start going,
they banter back and forth.
She's always right.
He never went to one fucking trumping
them over and over again.
And I'm listening to it.
I'm like,
I'm going to open this door and I'm
going to jump this fucking car for rich.
This is brutal.
It's one of the few podcasts I do listen
to.
Yeah.
What,
what,
um,
what do you have on your show now?
You and your channel and the weekends.
You have our show,
our show,
the,
we call it friends of the show.
It's your friends with Charlotte's.
We call them a Richard Bonnie.
Um,
I think bobby's podcasts out there.
I Dunno.
We mix and match every weekend.
So.
And it's on Saturday and Sunday.
Is that what it is to leave?
So I don't listen to my channel.
So you guys don't,
you don't control when your show goes on
because look,
I love Ron Fez.
Yeah.
But I don't like the fact that when I
get up in the morning and from driving
around at 9:00
in the morning,
I don't hear you guys doing your show.
I hear Ron and Fez.
Well you've got to get the on demand
thing.
Yeah.
But when I'm driving,
I'm driving pretty fucking pot.
And if what it does is it connects to
your internet and then you could just
show,
it sounds like a fake person.
You could choose.
We had every episode you want and you
could download tomorrow or yesterday's
and hit play and it automatically play.
So it's kind of like itunes for Sirius
Xm.
Okay.
But can I listen to it today?
Yeah.
Yeah,
super fast.
I would love for our show to beyond,
of course,
you know,
in the morning drive.
So the archives right away,
I would love to have better,
but do have to have a three g connection
or some sort of a connection to pick it
up.
You always have that connection you
usually.
But yeah,
you have to have some kind of
connection,
some kind of connection.
I don't like your voice because the
satellite,
I don't have to have a connection
because I'm connected to the
motherfucking sky.
Bridges.
Storms.
Yeah.
Bridges,
storms or clouds.
Snow fucks it up as well.
That sure enough,
you ever get like direct TV snows out
fucking worse.
Good luck.
Why then you wish you had cable and you
pissed.
I don't know if I like the pure coconut
water.
You guys got a lot of freaky stuff
around here.
Coconut water.
It's very freaky.
I'm surprised it's a brain.
You're talking about.
How's coconut water?
Freaky,
freaky,
freaky shit.
I guess maybe I'm not describing it
perfectly,
but you got a new mood thing over there.
You got fucking Alpha brain over here
with freaky PPO.
I'm drinking pure coconut water.
It's very good for you.
Which I know is very good,
but I don't.
I don't.
I don't know.
I don't like it was surrounding you with
like organic items.
Wood and brick and and coffee made with
butter it together,
Bro.
Coffee made with butter.
It's bulletproof coffee.
It's fed butter.
I know it's one of your sponsors.
Mycotoxin free coffee.
I say that with love.
I know,
I know.
It's not even one of my sponsors.
I think I've heard you talk about it.
We sell it on on it,
but they're not a sponsor on.
It's one of our sponsors.
We started selling bulletproof coffee
because it's so good that the key is
trying to find coffee.
That's like.
It has very little mold in it.
You remember?
You can treat it too with coconut oil.
You ever have this starbucks coffee
where it's like the fucking really good
shit.
Only a few starbucks a it.
What is it?
It's Kinda like um,
what I remember they have a.
I think you even told me about this,
that some starbucks have this million
dollar coffee maker machine.
Yeah.
The others are machine guy made the.
He was a coffee freak and he made this
machine that bruise the beans to the
perfect temperature and all that shit.
Starbucks experimenting with that in
Boston.
You get a cup of coffee?
I actually had it on a.
What is it?
Boylston street again?
Yeah.
Is it Boylston?
Down Boylston.
Boston.
Is that where the finish line for the
marathon is?
What road is that?
I don't know,
I,
my roads fucked up.
I'm not a little man.
It goes around and running.
No,
he never ran.
I do run,
but I'm not to race.
Let's see.
Who actually was.
I was just teasing.
I was good.
Nothing wrong with running.
Anyway.
They were running 20 miles without
stopping.
No,
let's do that.
Why would I do that?
Just get in the car just so he could say
that this year.
But there's a starbucks over there in
Boston and it's like seven or eight
bucks for one cup of coffee.
So I had to try it.
It was amazing.
Is it the type of bean as wells as
special,
like fucking blue or green something.
Fucking coffee beans.
And they brew individual cups of coffee
and it takes a whole thing and it's like
Kinda,
it's almost like a pizza pie tray and
it's a,
it's a whole thing.
Your watch it being made the most
expensive coffee or drinking something
called Kopi Luwak.
No idea what it is.
It's um,
it's coffee beans that are eaten by an
animal called a civet right.
And it shits it out and when it hits it
out,
the coffee beans are not digested by its
body,
but
it's bodies,
acids,
stomach acid,
do something to break down the outer
area,
that outer heart area.
And then when you brew those beans it's
unbelievably smooth and delicious.
And it doesn't taste like shit.
Someone has to say it.
Sorry.
No,
I guess they clean it.
Just fucking drain the beans a little
bit.
They cleaned the shit.
I try that.
It's good.
I'm telling you it's delicious.
Where he gets a different.
You're going to specialty stores to get
an order online.
But the fact that someone likes coffee
so much,
they picked it out.
A pilot shit.
No kidding.
This little cunty fucking civic.
And you know,
they had been.
Someone had to try it for the first
time.
Yeah,
we'll think about it.
Anything that people have eaten yet?
We've,
we've lobsters and shit.
Someone had to go,
you know,
I think that might be tasty.
They had to give it a shot and they.
But I think at this stuff they,
they tried like,
you know,
someone had to try poison ivy.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
but the eight that they had to try all
that shit.
Then we finally said,
no,
leave that shit alone.
Yeah.
It's funny how some plants are delicious
for you and other plants will kill you
immediately and they all like sorta had
someone had a fucking figure that shit
out for us that they've all been
documented.
It's essentially into.
Except for like the rain forest,
there's they don't know what the fuck's
in there and you deal with like the
gigantic vast reaches of the Amazon and
how many plants are in there that we
don't even know about this.
It's very possible they send botness
down there all the time and they
discover new shit and we're just fucking
destroying.
Tell us it's no big fucking deal.
Well,
the.
Where's it Borneo?
Was it born here?
They keep finding new species.
They've been funding a bunch of new
species and then like tropical rain
forest,
new species of primates,
new species of bugs and these species of
birds.
It's like they're constantly finding all
these weird freaky fucking animals they
didn't even know existed and it's 2013.
We do not have a good inventory of all
the life on earth.
We got most of it though.
Not Big.
Todd.
I don't know.
What about lochness monster?
I think that's most likely horseshit or
it could be a just a big fish or an
eagle has to be you.
Now they've been.
They've been looking around enough.
Well then that didn't know.
Just look around enough.
They've actually trolled the sonars know
that and they thought it was a place.
Yes.
Or I think,
but if I'm not mistaken,
I don't think that animal breeze water.
I think that animal is supposed to be an
air breathing thing.
Like a whale,
you know,
that kind of situation.
Yeah.
And it's like.
I don't know though,
I don't know if they do,
they breathe the water,
but I just don't think that a dinosaur
could be alive today.
It just doesn't make sense to me.
But how cool would that be?
It would be pretty fucking cool.
That'd be cool.
Right.
You think will bring dinosaurs back?
Yeah,
I think they're going to do that
eventually.
We're going to start doing some of that
shit.
I couldn't imagine them not because
they're already talking about mammoth.
I think there's some Russian.
They're getting close scientists
figuring that out.
I just think either they're very close
to,
but they've only been extinct.
How many years?
13,000.
I was going to say somewhere in the
pleistocene.
Somewhere around the.
That's nothing compared to fucking
dinosaurs.
Yeah.
They don't know.
Uh,
they,
they think that they might have been
killed the same way they think that a
lot of speculation as to what killed off
the woolly mammoth,
but they think the woolly mammoth and
the tooth tiger might've been killed off
by meteors.
Really?
Yeah.
They think that,
um,
the,
uh,
the decline of the last ice age,
like the abruptness might've might've
been started or triggered initially by
meteor showers because they found that
about,
I think 12,000
years ago.
And the Strada,
when they do like coil soil samples,
you know,
12,000
years ago they found this type of glass
that exists at nuclear test sites in on
meteor impact sites.
And it's everywhere all over the earth.
So they,
they found in all sorts of different
countries and it's all in the same area,
so they're pretty sure that that's what
happened and they think that that
might've coincided with a lot of mass
extinctions,
including like the wooly mammoths and
saber tooth tigers because they found,
they found some areas really interesting
areas where they found like a lot of
bullying,
mammoth skeletons all together in one
place.
Like they all died together.
I don't know,
you know,
I tell what kind of classes that they're
fighting impact glass.
It's like,
what does it look like?
It's like greenish.
It's really kind of,
what is it,
like big huge pieces.
I don't think it's microscopic the
scopic unless,
I mean,
I don't want to say microscopic,
it's the wrong word.
I think it's,
it varies in size,
but some of it is small pieces that they
just find that's pretty cool in the uh,
well let me,
let me find it like,
so I can answer your question,
but impact glass glass 12,000
years.
Um,
yeah.
It's fascinating shit because what
they're saying essentially is that it's
most likely that if something like that
did happen,
a lot of people died and then it
might've killed off a huge percentage of
our population,
but it's so long ago that the stories
about it,
that the fables,
everything that was if there was writing
back then everything that was written
down,
it's gone.
It's long gone and it's my.
It might be very well that the amount of
civilization that we had back then was
like we were on our way to developing a
civilization,
but it's pretty remote and pre pretty
crude and then it got reset and then we
had to start all over again.
You think it was crude?
Might be if there's a lot of highly
intelligent beings before us.
Sure.
It's possible.
It's just as no evidence of it.
True.
What?
What have you found new evidence
somewhere and you found out?
Well in Greenland,
there's an alien ship that came here
from another fucking planet.
They found it in the ground and they
found all this alien fossils and they
had a whole city set up here.
One hundred million years ago,
you'd be like,
Whoa,
no shit.
You would.
Yeah,
I mean,
but until they find something like that,
you just talking to your ass,
you know.
Well,
that's what I said about bigfoot.
Said that about bigfoot.
Right?
You're right.
Except I defer to that lady that,
uh,
that late.
Yeah,
she knows a little bit more Jane
Goodall's.
She's a bad bitch.
She knows what the fuck she's talking
about.
But then again,
that could be just her super excited.
The melt glass at 1700 degrees equal to
an atomic bomb.
Meteorites are thought to have
triggered,
triggered a cold snap that killed off
every civil early civilization and giant
animals.
Yeah.
This is what they're thinking.
Evidence of this media rights,
intense heat was found on two
continents.
Researchers believed the huge,
huge cosmic impact triggered a vicious
cold snap which caused widespread
destruction.
The international team found a substance
known as melt glass,
which forms the temperatures of 17 whoa.
Seventeen to 100 degrees to 2,200
degrees Celsius and can result in a
cosmic body hitting the earth.
So that's what it's is a result from.
So they think that that's like one of
the leading.
Oh,
it's big man.
They have big pieces of the shit.
I thought it was small,
but look,
it's big.
It's in this case,
it doesn't look like glass though.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's created by it.
Well,
it does here more.
It looks like,
like melted glass right out.
You can just looking at sort of a weird
picture.
But um,
there's a,
there's a thing called the clovis
comment and uh,
that's uh,
uh,
a comment that they're,
an impact site that they,
they were uh,
researching too.
They're trying to figure out is around
the same,
same time around 12,000
years ago.
They think that uh,
that might've coincided with a lot of
the or might have rather been the source
of a lot of the stories of cataclysms
and like the old texts,
like the Sumerian texts and you know,
in the ancient stories from the original
Hebrew Bible,
like a lot of those cataclysmic stories
might've had something to do with it.
Retelling of the days of the impacts of
the meaning,
the showers.
Were you bored in school?
Yeah,
I was pretty bored.
because they weren't teaching this shit.
Well,
they were,
you know,
the problem with school is they're just
trying to get you to conform to sitting
in a chair and absorbing information,
doing what they asked you to do,
all that,
you know,
when you're,
you got a kid.
The way to get a kid excited about
learning is to get them excited about
learning something that he's interested
in of course.
And then once they do that.
Yeah.
And then once you do that then you know,
learning becomes fun for most of us.
Learning became a bore,
a burden.
It's A.
Yeah.
So I had to kind of relearn what
learning meant.
Now,
how you handle that with your kids?
In what way?
How were they learning?
Just traditional school.
Yeah.
Um,
but,
uh,
I mean,
are they having a good time with it or
are they going through the same shit we
did growing up because my kids are still
too young.
They're the start that next year.
I guess the,
the,
the four year old is in preschool right
now and it's fascinating to watch them
first start to interact with their
little friends and they're just starting
to learn things and they're learning
things and it's fun.
And what's really interesting to me is I
was watching the other day and they're
teaching this class and you know,
they're,
they're teaching them stuff and they get
excited when they raise their hand and
they
figured out and they're right and they
all like laughing and having fun.
I'm a lot happens where this stops being
fun.
Like how does this become the gross snus
that is nonchalant high school teachers
who don't give a fuck and kids in the
class.
I don't give a fuck and everybody seems
to be misguided and lost and ready to
fucking just get out of there and break
free.
I got to answer the first,
the first day they gave you homework.
I said it though,
I don't think you should do homework.
I agree with you.
Well,
school was absolutely fun until they
started fucking giving you homework and
if and,
and it was busy work.
Most of that shit was busy work and if
it did,
it looked,
you know,
only you can only focus on certain,
like one thing or whatever.
Whatever your,
your subjects already,
you're really trying to gather
information on.
You can only focus on them for a certain
amount of amount of hours in the death
course.
Otherwise you're going to lose the
absorption and when you force kids into
like getting home and then working out
what about the rest of their life,
you're going to make an imbalanced
person,
right?
If you're going to school eight hours a
day after that,
that should be good enough.
Should be an eight hours doing anything
a day should be good enough.
It's ridiculous.
You're not going to get it.
I'm going to handle that.
My son is almost three at preschool next
year in the fall and I don't know.
I don't.
I don't know how.
What are your thoughts on the way to,
you know,
I mean obviously you made a living in a
very controversial and I'm a unusual way
by,
by becoming a radio guy,
like very few people make it as a radio
guy,
so like mean a lot of parents,
they're big scare.
The big fear is what if my son or
daughter becomes a loser?
Right?
What if I fail to get them ready for the
real world?
And then they're out there and they
become like this big burden.
So then when they hear something like,
hey mom,
I want to be a radio DJ.
No son,
don't,
you know,
it's hard to make it in the radio
business.
The retail business has one of the
smallest rates of success of any
business in America.
Why?
Why do that?
Or do you go work with your funder and
stocks and bonds and mom,
my dad said,
go for it.
Well then your dad's a good guy.
He was an amazing guy.
Yeah,
he absolutely.
He told me from a very young age,
he said,
look,
find something you really enjoy because
you're gonna.
Have to do it for a long fucking time.
He didn't give a fuck if he wore a suit
or if we,
you know,
try to be a radio guy.
And he supported me.
He supported me every step of the way.
That's awesome.
And it's funny you say what you just did
because I remember my friends were so
fucking jealous of me because I was able
to go for my dream and they want to go
for the same fucking dream,
but they had the parents that you just
marked where they basically said there
was like five careers that were the hot
careers back then and they've basically
forced their kids to go to college to
get a job with one of those areas.
Yeah.
It was the safest route.
And those,
those guys,
they're miserable.
They're absolutely miserable.
Yeah.
And then you're fucked because stuck on
that path.
There's nothing he could do.
You get the mortgage,
you got the wife,
you've got the kids,
you've got the job.
That's a good job.
Like what are you gonna quit this good
job and then how are you going to live?
We're going to do.
You're going to be a musician now.
Really not your time to be a musician
was when you were 20.
And to be fair,
my dad always said have something to
fall back on.
Like he was aware that the odds were
against me,
but he's like,
you know,
make sure that you have something to
fall back on.
Which I never really did.
I just Kinda,
I was either going to do that and just
be a bomb or something I think.
But as far as my kid goes,
I just want him to just try every.
Everything,
whatever he enjoys.
Right.
Pursuing enjoys.
I always say that if there's a guy out
there,
anybody out there that's making comic
books,
you can make comic books too.
Okay.
If there's a guy out there who's making
movies you can make movies to.
You're a person.
You've got to figure out what he's
doing.
I'm not saying you're going to figure it
out.
You might not be able to figure it out,
but if it was so easy to do,
everybody be doing it.
Okay,
but if someone's doing it,
it can be done,
right?
It doesn't.
You know,
you have to figure out and along the way
you learned about yourself and you learn
about getting shit done.
You learned about making things happen.
Of course,
that's what people don't learn when they
take the safe route and they save the
take that safe route,
they,
they don't learn about making shit
happen.
It'll learn about the thrill of carving
a life out of something that's like a
really difficult business like the radio
business,
like you've got to kick back at the end
of the day and go,
hey,
fuck it.
I'm opie from opie and Anthony.
It's one of the biggest radio teams in
the history of the business.
A 10 year period.
At the end of the day,
there's no one can take that away.
That's pretty fucked up.
It's fucking awesome.
That's the only thing I've done in my
whole life,
but it's good.
Eighteen years old,
but it's great.
And to think about how few of them,
how few people who get into radio ever
get to be an opening and a few people
get to be on a show like opie and
Anthony,
a few,
and they were scared to take the chance.
So you can understand why your parents
would be reluctant to try to encourage
you to do that kind of a dream.
If you don't want your kid to be a loser
and you see something like radio,
you're like,
ah,
it's fucking kid.
I wonder what.
I wonder what they really thought were
they weren't talking to me when I was
away doing this fucking thing.
I wonder if they,
you know,
I wonder if they had conversations like,
oh fuck,
I hope he gives up on that.
You know,
fortunately one of these days,
my parents didn't have any influence on
me by the time I was 21.
There's nothing they could say.
I was so stubborn like I have.
When I had it in my mind,
I was like,
it didn't matter to me.
So when I started doing standup comedy,
my mother was like,
wow,
I never really thought you were that
funny.
I don't think.
Yeah,
my mom didn't think I was funny at all.
I think,
uh,
I,
I never looked back at 18.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I,
I came from a,
you know,
kind of a strange upbringing.
My mom was fucking mentally insane and I
knew I had to get the fuck out of there.
So when all those stories about your dad
and the gambling,
gambling,
you know.
Fuck.
Was that,
I don't know.
No,
no,
no.
My Dad wasn't a gambler.
No,
I'm sorry,
I confused you with somebody else.
Who the fuck that I confuse you with?
Oh no,
that sounds like a good story.
Shit.
God dammit.
All right,
forget it.
So
now I need to know your mom was nutty.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Do you feel like you have any of that
nutty sauce working around your brain?
I'm sure we all do.
Not like,
not like she had.
No.
She had,
she was dying.
She diagnosed with OCD,
but she's scared all sorts of shit going
on now.
What would they do for it today?
If it went today?
They would hook her on Medicaid.
Yeah,
but I mean the pills that come a long
way,
you know,
but back in the day,
man.
Holy Fuck.
Yeah.
If you were stuck,
if your mother had a mental illness back
in the day,
nobody did anything about it.
They're not.
They didn't have any results.
She went away.
She would go away to mental hospitals
and as kids we were like,
where's mom?
Oh,
she's visiting like a long lost fucking
relative.
Oh,
she would be gone for a week or two at a
time.
Yeah.
And they did.
They did the electric shock treatment
back then,
the bad kind a,
they've been able to pinpoint that shit.
So when they do give you,
let's recap,
now they,
they kinda,
they understand a little better,
but back then they were just frying the
whole fucking brand and hoping they
returning some shit off.
Oh yeah.
What's really interesting when you look
at like respected peer reviewed medical
journals from like the 16 hundreds and
shed thought you could love bottom eyes
people.
Totally cool thing to do.
Man.
I don't know what year it was where they
lobotomized people,
but I'm making the number up,
but whenever they used to do it,
like you know,
they thought that was the way to do it.
Right?
Like this is a good middle of fucking
stick in there and scrambling,
put some day they're going to look at
the shit we're doing today and going
into these idiots back then thought this
was the right thing.
Oh yeah.
Like,
you know,
artificial hips,
artificial hips tweaked me out.
Like I can see when someone needs them
and you know,
you gotta do what you gotTa do,
but I know in a few years they're going
to be able to regenerate a hip.
Of course they're going to be able to
figure out to do some really nutty shit.
They built a woman's bladder.
They made a fake bladder.
Yeah.
They built it in a fucking.
I Dunno how it built it,
right?
Do you use some sort of tissue from her
skin and constructed a bladder one and
then put it in her body didn't work.
I don't know.
This is a test.
Her urine.
I don't drink other people's urine,
just my own.
I don't even drink my own anymore.
I tried it a few times.
I tried.
It's not that bad.
It wasn't bad.
Yeah,
it was.
Yeah.
It's one of those things where you can
survive on a boat if you drink your
urine or you could die of dehydration.
Let's see.
Fucking pussy.
You know what I'm saying?
I hear you saying that as a father you'd
be able to kill a deer if your kids were
hungry and you knew that's what you had
to do.
Brewer.
Brewer told me the greatest thing about
being a father when he goes,
when you become a father,
you completely understand that you could
kill another human being.
Oh yeah.
I didn't understand that.
My wife was pregnant at the time and I
was hanging out with her and you know,
you get all this advice from all your
friends and that's what he told me.
Had Boys at the fucking truth,
man.
Oh,
it's totally.
Yeah.
I'm a lunatic father at the playgrounds.
Are you?
You a little kid watching my son's
coming down the slide.
Oh No,
not that bad,
but there was a,
there was a girl that pushed my son
right into a pole bad and I had a little
girl.
My Shit.
Well she was bigger than my son,
but still,
what,
three or four?
He was probably a year and a half at the
time was a little girl,
uh,
a yelled in,
like,
just like in general,
but the kid was pretty damn scared out
of my mind because the parent wasn't
around.
I was like,
who's I started screaming,
starts screaming,
who's fucking kid is fine because my kid
is like,
you know,
when you see your kid cry,
it's brutal,
right?
Yeah.
It's pretty brutal.
I mean,
you know,
I've learned since then you've got to be
a little cooler about it.
But I lost my fucking,
my shit because she went right at him,
you know,
he was being an innocent little kid.
Just kind of like shadow playing with
them and following them around.
She turned around and gave him a shove.
He went flying to this poll.
I thought he was fucked up to say that
most kids that do that,
like physical kind of stuff,
it's because that's happening to them.
Uh,
no.
Yeah.
Well we all know kids are sponges,
right?
Yeah.
They say when kids react violently,
like out of,
out of sort like that.
I kind of believe that.
Yeah.
I noticed the most kids are passive
aggressive assholes.
You go to the playground with your kids.
Oh yeah.
How do you handle it?
I just let him play.
And you let him get like thrown out.
I have a two and a half year old and I
have a four and a half year old,
so four and a half year old.
I've watched her lose a little bit more
distance,
but the two and a half year old I
mirrored her.
I'm there.
I'm her shadow wherever she goes.
No,
I let I let my kid get roughed up a
little bit,
but not that,
you know,
being pushed into.
Well,
it just doesn't seem very necessary.
Yeah,
I would definitely say something,
but it wasn't really badly hurt.
Yeah.
I'm trying not to scream,
you know,
but it's hard when you're even
embarrassed.
I lost it and then some parents came up,
but it wasn't her kid.
It was like a friend of the,
of the parent that was watching the kid
and she's trying to go at me and I'm
like,
look,
you don't even know what the fuck she
did.
Was she saying because I'm yelling,
so she thinks I'm yelling at her kid.
I'm like,
I'm technically not yelling at your kid.
Um,
I am losing it because as you see,
my kid is screaming over here and yeah.
And I,
and I go,
you don't even know what the fuck
happened?
I said,
fuck right.
I go,
well,
do you were,
were you,
you weren't watching your kid.
Uh,
yeah.
People get real defensive.
It's very emotional when you're dealing
with children and injuries and shit.
And when you,
um,
when you like see how fucking wacky the
world is getting,
do you worry about the future?
Each other fucking mean you guys as part
of your show,
you're constantly covering everything
that's fucked up about the world and
this constant stories.
And it's brutal.
Yeah.
I,
I kinda liked the days where I just had
to worry about myself.
Yeah.
I also,
I also know that I will absolutely take
one before my kid does.
Right.
I know I will jump in front of a car and
all that shit now.
Well obviously,
yeah,
that we hope it doesn't.
Course
I did all that shit,
you know,
plays into it being a father.
You're like,
oh my God,
this is all stuff I've never had to
think about or worry about.
This world is beautiful in certain spots
for certain amounts of time.
And the key is trying to take those
certain spots where it's beautiful for
certain amounts of time,
extended amount of time and spread out
the spots.
Nice.
You know that that really is.
I mean,
think about obviously we all like
people,
right?
And we all love people.
We all love people.
You know,
there's,
we all have really good friends.
We all have family,
we all have people that we enjoy seeing
in movies.
The key is to bring everybody else into
that,
like sort of a,
an environment like this.
This idea that we need constant
conflict,
I think that's all,
some outdated ape shit and I think that
that needs to be looked over and move
forward and it can be managed and done
with conflict.
Yeah.
It's so stupid after awhile.
I mean the,
the fact that every fucking day in the
news we're talking about going into some
new country and there's some new,
uh,
al Qaeda strong point.
Did you hear about that shit?
This is some new talking point.
Oh really?
Oh yeah.
They'll have an island and like Malley,
there's some place called molly.
Where's molly?
Do you know where Melia?
Brian,
anyone?
Malley Malley.
Google manage silly goose.
It's mally mal.
I.
So this is the.
Somebody sent me this tweet,
I don't know how correct he as he says,
al Qaeda moves to mally.
Just so happens molly has gold and
mineral deposits of course.
Oops.
Which is hilarious.
So,
uh,
out in the headline in the world,
news on Yahoo is al Qaeda carves out own
country in Mali that al Qaeda has its
own country.
All of a sudden,
all of a sudden,
deep inside caves and remote desert
basis,
it sounds like you're reading something
from the fucking 19 fifties.
When it was propaganda films,
he'd been sad.
This is how it actually starts on Yahoo
knows yahoo news deep inside caves and
remote desert basis in the scarp mints.
It's an escarpment.
The escarpments and cliff faces of
northern Mallee,
Islamic extremist fighters have been
burrowing into the earth erecting a
formidable set of defenses to protect
what is essentially become our titus
newest country.
Africa.
They got,
they got a layer that is,
it sounds like they're living in the
middle of a mountain that is Wacko
propaganda.
When did that,
a couple of days ago?
Um,
I think it's today.
I think it's Today's news I haven't
really checked into 10 hours ago
apparently.
I mean,
I don't know if that's true.
Maybe it is true.
Maybe there really isn't.
Al Qaeda has a fucking country all of a
sudden there.
You know,
I haven't,
I haven't turned on CNN,
Fox,
MSNBC,
and like two or three days.
It's kind of Nice.
It seems like the government wrote that
though,
I can't believe that a journalist wrote
that the way this is written,
it's almost like the government said,
here go like this.
It's almost like the government hired
some gay guy hiding from the fact that
he's gay and he's very creative and he
writes and he has a boyfriend,
but no one can know,
and so he writes this kind of shit for
them.
They pull him aside and say,
listen,
we need something that really gets
people excited about us going over to
molly and taken over that gold,
so do what you gotta do and you have a
fancy little typewriter and say hi to
your boyfriend for me in this gay dudes
sweating it out,
drinking bourbon.
Lincoln is glass together.
This is what one side King Center
imagination you got in the escarpments
carpets.
Escarpments is this phrase only a gay
man uses only a gay man under the
influence of alcohol is trying to come
off as being a little bit more literate
and verbose in his scarp mints and cliff
faces,
northern Mallee,
Islamic extremist fighters,
Islamic extremists fighter.
That's Kinda scary.
I've been barreling into the earth.
You have a picture of these fucking
people.
Please.
Can I at least see one of them satellite
photos?
Do you ever leak
a leak in what?
I got to take it.
A leak.
Oh yeah.
Go take a leak,
man.
Go ahead.
I can handle it.
I have a fucking powerful bladder
drinking coffee the whole fucking time.
Like I told you.
Oh,
I got a powerful bladder.
How much time do we have left on this
program?
It's like not even 5:00.
Twenty minutes.
We almost did three hours.
Ope already.
That's pretty good.
Crazy.
I think.
I think we did good.
Then you want to wrap it up right now?
No,
I don't care.
You go take a leak and then come back.
We'll talk about some other shit.
Opie took notes.
It's a fucking goddamn professional.
He knows what he's doing.
It's the most professional out of all
the radio guys we've ever had on the
show.
One of the radio guys we had on the
show,
so Norton Norton's comic as well.
We need to get tom like on.
I know Kevin Smith back on.
Yeah,
we need to get to,
I got to do his show next.
I owe him one,
but then he'll do ours,
but we have to do it that way because I
did him first and then he did us.
That's why I'm io,
but I'll do it and then a,
they'll do us again.
Hm.
It's a big swap off.
But uh,
we got a lot of good guys coming up.
We're going to do what David Cho with,
uh,
with Yoshi.
He's coming up soon.
We got a Dunkin,
most likely it's going to be here
tomorrow,
but a Dunkin is undergoing a,
his first doses of chemo,
so.
Oh No.
Yeah.
So He's,
he's very optimistic though.
The type of cancer that he had his
papers to the trouble.
Yeah.
He has to do a,
a version of it.
I don't know exactly how it works.
He'll uh,
he'll explain it to us because it's
pretty interesting.
Like he was,
he was explaining to me on the phone
today they,
uh,
this particular type of cancer,
testicular cancer,
a lot of research has been done and
apparently they're very good at nabbing
it,
stopping it.
And a very good at,
you know,
bringing people back to being cancer
free.
Scary Shit though.
Scary Shit.
When a friend has something like that,
you should check out the movie 50 slash
50.
It deals with seth and then
the guy from looper and stuff and I just
watched it the other day.
It's on Netflix and it was kind of
interesting to watch,
you know,
like a young kid getting this cancer and
having to do like the cancer,
stuff like that.
I went on a date with a girl once she.
She died of cancer when I wanted a day
with her.
She was already suffering from cancer.
When my friend hooked us up together,
we went on like this double date.
She was very nice,
very nice.
She had something like,
I think she had her lymph nodes already
removed.
She had some,
some,
some issue like her neck had like a scar
on it and she wore a scar to cover up
this a scarf rather to cover up the
scar.
She was very pretty and very smart and
very nice and like so vibrant and full
of life.
She was such a fun person,
was hard to believe that she was on her
way out the door and then within a year
she was,
she was gone.
Oh yeah.
It was really weird,
man.
But uh,
you know,
my friend was like,
would you mind going on this double date
with,
uh,
with my,
my girlfriend's friend?
And I said,
yeah,
sure why?
He goes,
but I gotta tell you something,
she's dying of cancer.
And it was like,
oh,
okay.
So I go,
okay,
that's a tough sell for me.
She was a tough sell for anywhere she
was.
She was alive.
She was,
if she did wind up dying of cancer,
but the night that we went and hung out
and she was very alive and she was
laughing and happy and it was weird.
It was weird to know that I was saying
that she had already had an operation.
She wore a scarf because she had a big
scar on her neck,
something.
She had something removed from her neck,
but she was still like really pretty and
really fun.
And she was only 27 or 28 I think.
And then how long ago was this?
Long Time?
A long,
long,
long time ago.
It was in the nineties and she died.
It was crazy.
You know,
it's weird to think that your body can
just go wacky on Ya.
And literally your body starts growing
shit that's not supposed to be growing
there.
And it enters into your system.
And then before you know it,
you've got a real problem and
everything's shutting down.
Just going to check out.
Horrible.
Yeah,
that's,
that's great.
Joe.
Um,
I went to the bathroom.
What the hell happened?
I heard through the grape vine that a,
you,
there's a video out of you being on top
of the fucking Chrysler building or
something.
Is this,
is this true?
Did you,
did you get into the bowels of the
Chrysler building with some fucking
nutty dude and he climbed up on top of
the roof and you got like a video of
this.
Is that possible?
Or there's no video.
There's no video.
There's no video out,
there's no video out.
It hurts.
Well,
the rumor is you heard through the
grapevine.
The rumor is that,
I don't know.
I'm,
I want to say anything,
I'll just tell you what I've heard.
Rumor is that you have a video that you
were there personally,
while some fucking lunatic was climbing
out onto the actual eagles that overhang
on the Chrysler building,
so he's literally walking around on this
metal that is not designed to carry a
fucking grown man.
By the way.
Imagine that.
Metal would be slippery.
Slippery as fuck.
He's got street shoes on and he's
standing on top of this thing and it's
how many floors you're seeing this.
How many floors is it might be 60
stories.
Jesus,
fuck that guy's nuts.
Not seen this.
Huh?
I've heard this is what I heard is what
I've heard.
Is it true?
Is it gets really windy up there.
Is it real?
How do you.
How do you get there in the first place?
Fuck.
How does one get there?
Let's say hypothetically,
how would one get there?
Get there.
If you were writing a novel that was
exactly how it all went down,
how would you have the characters do it?
This is a novel.
This is all fiction,
so you're in.
This is.
This.
Didn't actually happen,
but if it did happen in your book and
your book,
How would the guy do it?
Well,
tell me a little nervous.
Listen,
don't be nervous.
There's nothing he can do.
This is all hypothetical.
We've already laid that out.
Well,
the Guy Moses that took me Undergrad,
he,
you know,
he knows some things.
He's done some things.
He might have been on the Eagle.
It was him.
The same guy.
He might have been.
He might have been on your book and your
book,
his book.
You'll be.
You'll be writing this book that's
coming out in March.
Oh yeah,
there.
That's the thing.
That's the slipper eagle that
motherfucker's stood on that.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Just why?
Looking at my skin's crawling.
My assholes quivering.
I haven't even talked to my hands are
sweating crazy.
I haven't even talked about this on my
own show yet.
What did you do?
What happened?
Tell me what the fuck he's going to be
so fucking pissed off.
Shit.
What I mean,
but you can word gets out there.
The Internet has no secrets.
Well,
why would he take me on this amazing
tour and it allow me to tow and allow me
to film it,
you know,
because maybe he's a crazy.
That's why he's fucking climbing around
on metal eagles.
Sixty nine store.
What if he slipped and you look up his
bucket list?
Moses Gates.
What if he slipped off and you had that?
I had my first anxiety attack,
panic attack.
Looking at that,
uh,
when I went home that night,
over and over,
over and over again,
I,
I pictured him falling from that Eagle.
What would you have done?
Would you have gotten in trouble if he
didn't,
do you think,
how am I going to explain that?
I think you would have been okay.
How?
How do you know I didn't push them?
You have good lawyers.
Why would you push them and him sitting
on Jesus Christ.
Is that him?
So it's on the Internet,
right?
Okay.
So he's a crazy fuck.
Photos of him.
It's on his God damn twitter page op.
A photo of him on his fucking twitter
page is him that's sitting on that
Eagle.
So you don't have to worry.
That's Moses Gates.
He said cities,
hidden cities.
Uh,
Fuck Moses.
The TV show,
I swear to God,
what's wrong?
There's nothing wrong with that.
Well,
a book.
I did make a kind of a promise of the
guy.
His book comes out and March Kim in his
promises.
Dude's got a picture of him standing on
top of thing on his twitter page
basically like,
Hey,
don't tell anybody that I'm standing on
top of this thing.
Meanwhile he's got a photo of it
basically.
All right,
if you have a photo of it.
So we went off the hook,
we went under ground,
the mole people used to live and then he
goes,
I want to show you something else.
So I go,
all right,
I'm up,
but he won't tell me.
We take a cab ride and I kind of seen
the distance.
It's the Chrysler building.
I'm like,
I think he's fucking taking me to the
Chrysler building.
Oh Shit.
And uh,
all of a sudden we got past security.
His name was on a list and uh,
we went in the elevators and we went up
to,
I think the,
I want to say like the,
well,
I don't know,
I don't want to say,
but in the fifties and then all of a
sudden we get out of the elevator and do
a quick dark to the,
uh,
the stairwell and then we went up
another,
I don't know,
like maybe seven or eight floors and
next thing you know,
there might've been a door unlocked.
That isn't an office that is abandoned.
And from that you can get that office
allegedly to the bowels or rather the
peak the attic.
Oh Wow.
You're going there.
I thought I was doing the first part of
the story.
God was this.
So,
uh,
this abandoned office leads to,
I think it used to be an observation
deck back in the day,
but the railings really low.
It's only about four feet.
I think.
Something like that.
People didn't give a fuck back then.
No.
And that's harder people and that.
And you're looking at it right now.
If you're watching,
you know,
watching this podcast,
that's the iconic eagles that had been
in a shitload of movies and whatnot.
I'm telling you right now,
a lot my fucking hands are sweating.
Looking at that picture,
my hands are sweating.
My toes were wiggling back and forth.
I'm shitting my pants.
I'm just going to unload them my fucking
cyber right now.
So this guy knew that the,
the office space was abandoned and this
guy knew also that the door was unlocked
so he knew how to do it when he'd
gotten.
He's obviously,
he's taking fucking pictures up there.
Well there's,
there's a,
there's a whole network of people.
They go to each other cities and do this
shit.
So I'm on top of each other's rooms and
whatever.
This is good.
This video is that guys on the ground
and like old water tunnels and there's
guys like climbing the fucking bridges
and all that Shell of being up there
lesbians.
So we had to go up.
So then the door was the door to the
outside was open sliding door and then
it's like an old fucking observation
deck with those eagles.
And then as I'm at,
as I'm at one of the eagles just kind of
filming shit,
all of a sudden I look over and he's
standing on the head of the Eagle.
He doesn't even tell me.
So yeah,
there you go.
There's the picture of soaking wet.
And then he did it again and that I do
have a video of them doing it.
Fuck it.
I do have,
when he turns around and get back to
safety,
I saw the slight slip.
I saw how it would happen.
Oh my God.
Where that's all it would take because
this thing is like Kinda.
It's first of all,
it's not flat.
It's,
it's it,
it's some kind of metal which looks
really slippery.
And there was a wind.
The wind was about 30 miles an hour that
day.
And I saw him turn around and that just
slight slip.
I'm like,
that's how it would have happened.
So when I went home that night and I saw
that play over and over again in my head
and I had my first fucking anxiety tech.
I'm a middle aged man.
I've never had an anxiety attack before
my heart was pounding out of my chest.
I woke up my wife and she had a fucking
calm me down because over and over again
I saw him fucking fallen.
If I was there,
I would have given you a hit of some of
this shit and it will put you right over
the edge.
No Shit right there at that moment.
Then you give a hit of that green crack
and he'd be like,
what?
And then we might have done other shit
watching that.
Just watching.
That almost gives me a heart attack.
So I got video of him going out and
kissing the head and he's a crazy man.
It's crazy.
Yeah man.
That's those things break off and then
it kills people below to.
What do you mean breaks off?
If it broke off,
what if,
what if his weight.
It's just not designed to carry 180
pound man or whatever the alleyways.
Oh there he is on twitter.
So yeah,
he's crazy as fuck that.
All right.
So that part of the story.
I could tell that thrill.
We know who we have coming in.
Folks.
We have Alex honnold.
Do you know who Alex honnold is?
Alex honnold is,
uh,
he's coming in on the 28th.
He's that kid who free climbs.
He Free Solo climbs like things that go
backwards.
So like he's hanging off and climbing
and pulling himself up like thousands of
feet.
He resold climbs places that nobody else
can do.
What about the guy I forgot his name and
Jim Norton's a big fan of is the guy
that climbs outside of the buildings
without any anything.
Who's at a French dude?
Somebody helped us out.
He climbs buildings.
There's a million videos online.
It's Spiderman guy is.
It's.
Does he call himself list spite on my
hands.
I am less spatter,
but there's a video where he was
climbing a building and they made them
wear a harness.
He didn't want to.
Yeah.
This video of him fucking slipping.
It would have been his death maybe,
but maybe because of the harness.
That's why he slipped.
Say you always got an answer.
Seems like you always have a safety net.
You'll fall.
You're always thinking out of the box.
Cop didn't have a safety net and that's
why you're successful in this radio
business.
If you had that safety net was logan
bend,
what does that.
This is the world's largest building in
China.
This is the guy climbing this fucking
thing.
Spiderman guy.
He uses a suction cup.
Things.
Oh my God,
but he's got a court.
Is this the time when he had the safety
net?
The safety line.
Oh my God.
Look at this guy you've never seen.
This guy knows pretty much every tall
building in the world up just hanging
off the side like it's no fuck outta me.
Shit.
My pants shitting my pants.
Just watching them.
No Shit.
I that.
That is the
fear of heights thing,
man.
Looking over the edge of a building.
There was many times while we're filming
fear factor,
we were at the top of buildings and that
would just freak myself out and just
look over the edge of the Chrysler
building.
That was pretty amazing.
That's one of the tallest buildings in
Manhattan,
right?
Yeah.
Without with the World Trade Center
towers.
Is that number one state building number
one?
Empire State building?
Well,
no,
I said the new freedom tower,
wherever the fuck they call it is now
officially taller and the Freedom Tower
is not done yet,
right?
No,
no.
It's almost,
they're really.
When is it going to be done?
Maybe next year.
That's got to be crazy to live in a city
and see something like that happen
because all of us that experienced
September 11th,
we experience it from the west coast.
You know,
it was creepy.
I,
I'll never forget the smell of a plastic
and death.
You could smell dramatic pause.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Like I,
I stayed,
I wasn't living in the city at the time,
but uh,
I stayed for a few days so we could
broadcast because they shut down the
whole fucking city.
And in midtown you smelled burning
plastic and you smelled death.
There was no doubt in your fucking mind
that was,
that was dead people all the way in mid
town.
I don't know how many miles officially
that is from ground zero,
but you know,
it's quite a hike.
And I also remember that some people
were just going about their day,
like nothing was different.
I remember like studying people,
I remember looking at these two women,
they were going to happy hour and they
were just talking about their dme
office,
you know,
their day at the office.
And I'm sitting there thinking to
myself,
Holy Fuck,
do you understand just what happened to
the city 24 hours ago?
Oh God,
I never,
never forgot that.
Yeah,
it's weird how people can do that.
It's weird if some people can just kind
of shut off and disconnect to that
because most of the people living in New
York,
they were all like,
holy fuck.
But you did see these other people that
they basically their,
their lives didn't change that day.
I noticed that when I went to work that
people were friendlier.
The people got a lot friendlier beyond
friendly.
All of a sudden like you're looking
people in the eyes.
Like when you live in New York City,
you don't look at anybody.
Yeah,
it's a very lonely place.
There's so many people,
but it's not weird.
It's a lonely place.
Like there's no one looks at anyone.
No one strikes depending conversations.
Very rare,
but after nine slash 11,
everyone was talking to each other.
It's really cool.
It's a weird thing about New York or you
go to a big place and it's crowded with
people and no one's talking to anybody
and everybody's being themselves.
Unless they know they can get a buck
off,
you know?
It's very strange.
They know they can make money off and
then they're talking to you,
but in general you're not having that.
You know that small talk.
Like I live in a building.
I've been there for years.
I don't know anyone in my building.
No one talks to anyone.
I see the same people in the elevator
and I want to look at him like we know
each other.
How about we talk a little bit and I've
tried,
but I think you're a creep.
No,
it happens to everybody.
It'd be easy to say that,
but no,
but then when you do have a with someone
in the
elevator of my building,
you know they're visiting.
There's no doubt in your mind because
they're the ones that are having that
small.
They don't think you're creep when
you're trying to start up a
conversation.
Oh,
I don't know because I feel like God,
we've seen it so many times.
I don't think I'm doing anything out of
the ordinary.
I never liked that about New York.
I always thought that was really
unfortunate that,
that,
that sort of a behavior exists,
right?
People like real standoffish with each
other.
And one of the things that I liked the
most about living a when I lived in
Colorado was a few people there where
there's only a 100,000
people in Boulder.
People are very friendly,
you know,
because it's just less,
less burnout.
It's like,
you know,
you're around people all the time.
You're like,
fuck,
we can get the fuck away from me,
but then if you see somebody that you
haven't seen it forever,
you're so happy to see them.
It's like you to find.
You have to strike a balance point.
I don't think the balance point is
stalking people up 70 funding stories
high and I kind of miss when I used to
live in western New York,
it was more of a small town mentality.
Have you guys ever earlier,
have you ever thought about moving
somewhere else?
You and Anthony ever thought about not
living in New York and just fucking
taking the show on the road somewhere?
Oh hell no,
no,
no.
I don't.
I don't even know how many more years
we're going to do it.
What are you gonna do?
If you don't do that?
Just chill out for a awhile.
The Fuck Outta here.
What are you gonna die going to get old.
I'll fall apart.
Can hang out with him right back and
just chill out.
Know you guys should do it for real.
You should do.
Exactly.
We're trying to figure out what's next
for us to do exactly what you're doing,
but do it on the Internet because that's
what's going to be in everyone's fucking
stereo.
Everyone's car stereo is going to be
connected to the Internet.
We probably should have made the leap
this last contract,
but you can make the leap to years
slowly,
you know,
you could just do it under assumed names
that everybody knows,
you know,
he could come up with your own name,
fucking Douchey,
you know,
whatever.
Call it.
I think a Dale Dudley.
They call themselves teabagging taint.
I think he's got some sort of a,
a contract issue,
things like that.
Just do it and just start it up with
what could they do.
I've done it for a long time.
I know,
but it's easy and it's fun.
I'm just looking for something new and
different.
Oh yeah.
Like what?
I don't know.
That's the problem.
Hmm.
I don't know.
I've been fooling around with this
video.
The west coast.
Come on out here,
man.
I've had a lot of fun because I'd have a
video on desk squad.
Bring you full circle.
It's podcasts.
Will fucking make some videos.
I can squat and be right next to Kevin
Pereira.
Yeah.
So I hope Moses isn't pissed.
Abby.
Listen,
Moses is a crazy fuck and he's got other
things to worry about.
How about his need to climb on top of
that Eagle?
He's crazy.
Asshole and then we might have done
other shit.
I don't want to hear it.
And I'm getting nervous.
My hands literally or sweaty or wet.
It was wet.
That was.
Yeah.
It'll come out.
It'll come out in March because I sort
of promised the guy,
well woopsies,
but if his,
if he's sitting on the Eagle on his
twitter.
I guess where I right with that.
Yeah.
These,
uh,
Alex honnold guy that we've got coming
in,
you know,
we were talking about him.
I told Steve Rinella.
I go,
yeah,
I got Alex honnold is coming in.
He's going to do the podcast.
Goes better.
Get Him in as quick as you can.
Those guys ain't going last.
I don't even know who he is to be honest
with you.
He's the climber Guy.
The Free Solo that.
Oh,
okay.
Right,
right,
right.
He better get him in because he's not
going to last.
He's going to fall right eventually.
I don't know.
Maybe not.
He knows what he's doing.
Shit that takes fucking balls.
You ever see those guys like those,
those real mountain climbers where they
have to be up there for the night and
they set up their fucking.
You can't even call it a tense and
whatever the fuck the apparatuses that
is just hanging off the side of it and
they and they were able to get a good
night's sleep.
How the fuck did you do that?
You know,
if you roll over and you're sleeping
right up the edge and then you realize
as you feel your back touch the ledge.
All my God,
I'm going off in the tent.
No,
you're,
you're off the ledge.
These,
these sleeping.
I don't know what they're officially
called.
You're actually off the ledge sleeping.
Somehow they hammered into the side of
the fucking.
Oh Jesus Christ,
cliff or whatever.
Can you can find a picture that is
insane.
What is it called?
I don't know.
He'll,
he'll find it,
but they set it up because you know,
their climb.
Is that,
that fucking long and they got to like
camp out for awhile and there's no,
you know,
they're on the side of the fucking.
What do you think of those crazy fucks
that kitten,
those wingsuits saying?
Did you see that one video?
It doesn't look jumps,
attend,
things like that.
Yeah.
Just hanging off the side and,
and,
and it's somewhere in your brain.
You're like,
yeah,
this is cool.
I'm going to,
I'm going to now sleep and then I'll
continue my climb in the morning.
So insane.
Yeah.
What are the,
what are those?
Oh my God.
Look at how that is set up.
That is the craziest fucking thing I've
ever looked at in my life.
Really?
And you've seen some shit.
Those things are crazy.
They're hanging those things off the
edge and they're just sleeping in those
little tent things.
You gotta you gotTa.
Hope that what?
However you fucking fast,
you know,
put to the side of the.
Yeah,
the rock face that it's going to be.
All right.
Fucking Bananas Open.
That one up Brian.
That one looked like just having the one
to the left of that.
Oh my God.
It is hanging out.
Reading the is so fun.
Seeing this one before raising.
I'm Kinda happy that I was able to turn
you onto.
Oh my gosh,
these people are not.
You're always turned me onto some shit.
I finally got got one for you.
Could you do that?
Oh,
I mean,
I guess I could,
but I wouldn't like it at all.
All my instincts.
The last.
I don't know.
I mean,
you're essentially like shutting off
that part of your brain that tells you
you're,
you're shitting your pants.
Fuck.
You know,
it tells you you could die with one
little slip.
Those guys die all the time.
Those climber guys,
that's a.
that's a crazy life.
Of course you might.
You might make it,
you might be fine.
So what's up with the wing suits?
It does.
Cause rather than mom,
did you see the one video where the guy
thinks holding up the balloons or
something and the wing suit guy comes
flying through and I think it's on Vimeo
or something.
He's holding up a balloon tweeted the
other day.
It was just amazing.
He jumped off the top of a fucking
mountain and now he's flying through the
valley and,
and he's coming towards buddy.
And the buddy I think holds up balloons
or something literally right over his
head and he comes flying at.
You could barely see.
It's just like a flash.
Yeah,
they're going really fast.
They go like 100 miles an hour.
That is fucked up.
They're so silly.
Look at these motherfuckers climbing
this wall.
These people are so crazy.
You're,
you're a fingertip strength.
It's got to be ridiculous.
Oh yeah.
These guys can do mad chin ups to their
hand strength and their,
their ability to do chin ups.
It's fucking nuts.
What am I doing?
Like one finger chin-ups.
Mars works on our show.
I didn't see it.
I heard him talking about.
But I had to do something before we
start our radio show.
Last week there was a video he was
going,
this fucking guy's doing a chin ups with
one finger,
you know?
Have you seen it?
No,
but I believe it.
You believe it?
Yeah.
People can fucking.
Finger just takes time.
You know,
you start out with your full hand.
Then you work your way to four fingers,
three fingers to.
And the more you keep doing it,
you can do it.
Wow.
The guys can do chin ups,
pushups rather with one finger.
I've seen that one finger on each side.
Guys do pushups,
full pushups.
Amazing.
Supporting themselves with one finger,
right?
Yeah.
You can develop a crazy strengthen your
hands and your tendons.
It's like the difference between someone
who's really strong and someone who's
not really strong is at the summit is
really strong.
Oh look at this guy fall.
Looking at him.
He's being a dick head.
He's having fun.
The difference.
Having fun because he slipped and caught
himself and was okay with the difference
between someone really strong and
someone's not really strong besides
genetics,
is that someone is really strong,
forced their body to get strong by
making it lift weights a lot and keep
going and keep going.
Fuck you.
Lift away.
It's fuck you lift the weights.
So this Alex honnold guy and he's
climber guys,
they're constantly climbing and oh my
God,
this guy just felt look at this.
Oh Shit has got all in my God ain't
knows how to grab them.
You get a slam it to the side now,
but the impact that the impact,
I never had a discipline that line on
that thing that's supporting him.
That's so crazy because at that breaks
off,
man,
you're fucked and he's just silly around
their hands get super strong because
they just force them to.
They're constantly carrying shit with
their hands.
Their hands just get sick as fuck.
The kid is coming in.
He has his family there.
His fingers like sausage fingers,
so twice the size of a normal finger.
Really?
Yeah.
They just,
they just get huge from carrying his
weight.
He's not a big guys like they want to be
very slight,
big hands and be a slight person.
Carry yourself around that,
but you know,
it's a weird way to get you thrills,
you know?
Sure.
It's a weird way to just get your
jollies out of climbing the top of
something that can fucking kill you at
sleeping on the side.
Don't go to the top of the Chrysler.
We got to wrap this
bitch up.
Joe.
This was fun,
man.
You got me out of my comfort zone.
I'm so happy you came down to this.
I would.
This podcast owes you a lot man,
not just for naming death squad,
which is a ridiculous name,
but you know,
that deserves a twitter plug,
but anyone but not,
not just data,
but that's for Stan,
for creating a radio show that allowed
us to realize that there's a show in
[inaudible] talking because there's a
show and just hanging and that,
you know,
you guys make it so comfortable for us,
for comics to come in and fuck around.
And uh,
I think a lot of podcasts really
followed that lead.
I kind of,
I don't want to play that game usually,
but I kind of get that feeling.
A lot of the podcasts are very,
very much like one.
I feel like it,
you guys are the most unstructured of
all the major radio show told you that's
because we're lazy and it just worked
out because it works.
That's the right way to do it.
You're lucky to the lazy way's the right
way to do it.
We actually,
we used to like prepare for our show and
we,
that was like,
that was some of our worst shows that
because we did try to have structure for
awhile there and there's some days where
like we don't even know what the fuck
we're doing,
but by the end of the show we,
you know,
we had a good one.
You guys have an awesome group between
Norton who's in my opinion,
the funniest fucking guy was ever been
on radio ever.
He makes me how all that kind of regular
basis listen to that show just because
he's so perverted and twisted in these,
carved out his own little fucking slice
of the world with that,
you know,
his way and you know his way of
thinking,
so it's extra hilarious when he says
something crops up and then Anthony's
fucking bananas and you're crazy and the
three guys together know each other so
well and then you bring in comics.
It's just awesome.
It's been a good run,
man.
It has and it is for real is the reason
why we do this podcast today.
I guarantee you it has a lot to do with
it in a weird that someone will
acknowledge us.
Weird.
Yeah.
Not many people to really know what that
to feel left out.
Poor.
Oh No,
no.
Honestly it means a lot.
Thank you.
Listen,
I don't know how to handle that because
we don't.
We usually don't hear that.
Well,
listen,
you guys,
you,
you created the most fun environment and
radio for comics to come and hang out
and you brother.
And because of that you've had so many
funny fucking shows.
I mean,
it's just a brilliant,
brilliant run.
You know,
it's not like it's over anything.
I'm saying it like it's over.
Like you're retiring and shit.
I'll be on the radio tomorrow.
I stayed in La just for you.
Have you done live in the compound?
Have you done in the compound?
He's another reason.
Anthony is another reason why we do it.
That's why we started doing it on
ustream.
Yeah.
He,
uh,
he's not naughty motherfucker you work
with.
I love him.
I love that guy.
Yeah.
Well I'm going to be there.
Uh,
I think in April or something like that
or March.
So whenever there's a huge,
there's a UFC coming up there soon.
I'm taking her on the radio tomorrow.
I'm going to be there a day early just
to hang with you guys.
Or Joe.
I remember my brother.
Oop,
oop.
On twitter you creeps OPI radio at p I e
radio.
Thank you everybody.
And thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to teaching.
If you go Rogan.ting.com,
you can save yourself 25 bucks off any
of their super slick mobile devices to
get everything from flip phones all the
way to the sportiest most highly
advanced android phones,
all of it on the sprint network,
all of it with no contracts,
all of it from an ethical company.
And they sponsored this podcast.
So you know,
they must be the shit.
Thank you to on it.com.
That's o n n I t used the code name
Rogan and save yourself 10 percent of
any and all supplements.
All right,
you fucks.
Yeah,
you know what I'm saying?
Alright,
we will see you guys tomorrow.
Tomorrow we will be here with the one
and only Duncan trussell.
That's a just in case he might have to
bail,
so don't get too jolly for it because
he's going through radiation therapy for
ball Kansas.
Yeah.
But he's doing good.
Alright,
you're freaks.
See Tomorrow.
Maybe not soon.
A lot of shit going on.
Go by my special time.